no
we're gonna go live now okay story live
okay we are officially live episode
number 80.
is it really 80 michaels autumn sauce
and barry habib is back here with us
sporting a nice jacket and a shirt and
we got regular i mean
you're looking pretty good though you
got yourself i do what i can i do what i
can so i don't know what sometimes
you're just like casual sometimes you're
in a
three-piece suit i like being
unpredictable yeah yeah i wonder
is very predictable he knows what i'm
gonna be wearing and comfortable okay so
what happened to you today you said
something happened to you on the way you
got a speeding ticket on your bicycle
i just uh no speeding ticket on a
bicycle yeah those are the days
so i went i crashed a wedding this
weekend uh from a buddy of mine from
college i wasn't so much crashed i just
wasn't invited but they're like yeah
last minute a couple friends are coming
and i ran into a bunch of my friends
that i haven't seen in a while obviously
since covet and everything
and they're like yo sas like why don't
you uh be in the group chat
like with all the boys like like the
good old days i was like all right let's
let's give it a shot
wow did i not realize like everything we
talk about here um on more
you know right leaning you know open
ideas
my friends are super liberal like
they're yelling at me
i'm the weirdo conservative
in my friend group so obviously i don't
got to expand about what i'm talking
about
i'm not surprised no but it's so are you
expecting like no way
it's one of those things where it's like
i feel like ronnie dangerfield no
respect on the left they don't they're
they they talk [ __ ] they're i think i'm
an idiot they think i'm a maga guy i'm
clearly not
on the right they think i'm a soy boy
well i am soy man
they think i'm a socialist
you lost a lot of friends you know when
you were playing for the yankees
i thought you were going to tell us a
story like that yeah we've lost a lot of
good men out there
playing for the eggs playing for the
yankees i don't want to talk about it
trades free agency you never know
anyways this guy
crashes a 500 plate wedding that takes
save that money to a whole new world
my point is i'm in the middle i know
where i'm at now there's a birthday
coming up you might want to cry
somebody's turning 60 years old i don't
know if you know or not this man
who was a former president oh my boy
barack 60 years old
would you go to that party you're not
invited i'm surprised you're not invited
to how are you not on that list how do
they do that without anybody you never
know
anyways we got i heard that you might be
throwing a party for obama and trump
yes and maybe you're uh you know the
emcee of this one you know it's crazy so
this whole thing with five million
dollars
i was on fox and friends and we talked
about it and we've raised another
million dollars so we're shy of six
million dollars you give a ten you give
ten thousand dollars which was very nice
of you but
we're at uh uh uh uh shy of six million
you know what's amazing
you know what's the craziest thing about
the story here's what's the craziest
thing about story
one of the guys gave 137 thousand
dollars
okay now this guy who gave 137 thousand
dollars guess where he's based out of i
told you the story yesterday
he's a corporate lawyer from india
so in email we ask why are you giving
this 137 000
you don't even live in america look at
his answer he says you know what i'm
giving 137 000
because when u.s is at peace the rest of
the world does good hell yeah
when u.s isn't at peace we feel it i
want to see whatever i whatever i can do
to help
unify u.s the rest of us are going to do
better a
corporate attorney from india gave 137
000 trickle down socio economics
political go figure
yeah wow what a response have you heard
back from either of the
two camps we're talking right now to you
know both of them
you know not yet at the direct direct
contact i'm two away from the county
that uh is that like a million rupees
why 137 very oddly
by the way any any money you give today
in the super chat any money you give
today in the super chat 100 percent of
money give today the super chat's going
to go to
the the raising of the funds to make
that money go higher whatever you give
give
dollars ten dollars five hundred dollars
a thousand dollars whatever you give
it's gonna go to 100
of uh raising more money to make this
trump obama thing happen by the way i
got to tell you
more and more people talk about it the
more and more conviction goes higher
that this can this can happen
more and more have you thought about
what the first question you'd ask
the format i've thought about is the
following let me tell you what's that
what the what's the one that i'm most
excited about the format is
first hour i'm asking questions second
hour what the audience wanted to ask
questions because it's a long form third
hour
i say nothing i just simply moderate and
i sit in the middle and i say
what questions do you guys have for each
other and they talk the last hour is the
one up that run
i'm really looking forward to so lady on
twitter kaif can pull out this twitter
account
and show what she said whatever she said
many people have said the complete
opposite
on the other side so uh a lot of people
are making videos on youtube right now
talking about should this happen should
not happen people are writing articles
about the three china websites wrote
about this yesterday by the way just so
you know that's what we want
we have a big chinese following so keep
coming keep going keep going right there
so
we have this lady who says not this one
go back
uh go up go yeah keep going the
direction you're going okay right there
so she says
president barack obama should go nowhere
near trump for the rest of his life
neither should president biden or any
other honest caring elected officials
you gave his character honesty grace
strength and joy as a world leader the
circus is over happy
birthday early mr president it's more
like happy early birthday mr president
but it's okay
so then she retweets the the fox and
friends deal and then go back up
rochelle riley she's verified so i think
she's an author i said comments like
this is exactly why america is divided
the idea of both sides thinking they're
too holy to sit down with the opposing
parties how we got here
mlk was willing to sit down with just
about anyone to unite america be loyal
to america not just your political party
now guy makes a video says the complete
opposite thing
president trump should never sit down
with president obama because obama is
this obama's how we got here obama's how
would divide in america
so this isn't like a one-sided thing
there's both sides that don't want the
other person to sit there
but i'm gonna tell you this here couple
things number one um
who did president obama go meet with in
march of 2015 i want to say
who did he gonna meet with him i gotta
check my notes 2015 who did he go meet
with
in a country that he went and it was the
first president
since uh grover i don't know since
uh who was it since the president since
coolidge
that visited cuba he went and sat down
in cuba he was in cuba for three days
and he watched the baseball game with
him with raul castro raul castro
world's like are you kidding me you're
sitting down with a communist
in a regime like cuba and you're willing
to go laugh and watch a game with them
who did trump go sit down with in north
korea north korea
so if trump can sit with kim yong-un
and obama can sit with raul castro i am
sure they can sit down with each other i
agree
if those two can sit down with those two
guys you can definitely sit down with
each other because this is the
the the hamster wheels spinning up their
direction wasn't that like
clinton and george bush senior i mean
they've developed a great friendship
phenomenal relationship
different different opposing sides of
you know free enterprise or free market
system
i can very much see where them sitting
down together
is beneficial i i don't necessarily know
if like sitting down with a tyrannical
like despotic leader is is really that
that good like i don't i don't i don't
think sitting with chavez or sitting
with
role castro or even kim jong-un is
really
decision about whether that was good or
not we're not going to go back and
relive that
the point is if you sat with them
and half the country didn't support you
sitting with them
why are you not willing to sit down with
another president like yourself you know
and just don't have a conversation about
it before
this is they literally have something in
common that what only
four other living people five other
living people have in common
they've shared a space that literally
only uh
actual handful of people can even
remotely understand
um i would love to see it i think it
would it would be
it would it would be history you would
make history now how you can
convince them not to wear earpieces and
not just regurgitate talking points for
three hours and
you know i don't know but i don't i
don't either by the way i don't think
by the way here's the other part say
they do that it won't work
it will not work because both will call
the other one out
i don't think that'll work you have to
realize both of them
are pretty sharp and pretty bold neither
one of them are weak
and pushovers you're not dealing with a
biden and you're not dealing with
somebody on the right that's a easy
pushover that you may not want to debate
ryan okay you're dealing with somebody
that you know both of them are
heavyweights of their own side so
they're going to sit down with each
other and they have things to tell each
other great i think both are going to
hold each other accountable
but this goes down to your basically
your entire point in this podcast is
yeah come sit down discuss ideas
the best ideas will always win right you
say that all the time
not talking we learned that during you
know um
communism and uh the uh what's the
terminology they use for that the cold
war
not talking does nothing for you talking
you know i would love for you
to talk to my super liberal friends and
you guys find common ground
yeah like he is convinced that he's
right you want to kill him i know not
but there's no murdering going on here
said murder
slingshot to the son i get it but that's
what it comes down to is dialogue
you're not you don't make peace with
your i think we learned to make peace
with your enemies
i agree i think you unify unifying
starts off with sitting down having a
conversation you said the other day
uh you called it d
i mean we need more people in america
right now that specialize in in those
three diffusion unifying glue anyways we
got a lot of things to talk about we got
the eviction moratorium which you got
some updates for us here uh to tell us
what happened with there i think you got
uh why the fed is lying
we got some things to talk about their
interest rates mortgage rates drop to a
six-month low and refinances shoot
higher
uh we got a dorsi buying the company
google postpones return until october
uh olympics iranian athlete left this
country after being told to lose on
purpose
won silver at olympics for mongolia and
dedicated the medal to israel
we have a lot of different stuff that's
going on right now i'm trying to see
let's let's start off with
a light story pick any one of them pick
one story that's light that we can get
into let's let our special guest pick a
story
not real estate no i say i say we have a
let's start off with the eviction
moratorium what what pages
what page is that on what page is that
on kai tell me
is that uh page nine yeah go to page
nine okay go to page nine bottom of page
nine is where we're at
with eviction moratorium so i'm gonna
let's take a look at this this is
a story by the federal housing agency so
fhfa extends cover 19 reo eviction
moratorium
through september 30th 2021 on friday
the fhfa
announced that fannie mae and freddie
mac the enterprises are extending the
moratorium on single-family real
estate-owned reo's evictions until
september 30th the re-eviction
moratorium applies to prop properties
that have been acquired by an enterprise
through foreclosure or deed and lieu
of foreclosure transactions the current
moratorium was set to expire july 31 to
2021 the pandemic continues to have an
outsize impact on the ability of
americans to meet their monthly rental
mortgage payments today's extension of
the eviction moratorium
protect particularly vulnerable
americans who otherwise
would be at risk of losing a place to
live said acting director sandra
thompson
the re-eviction moratorium is just the
latest step fhfa has taken to benefit
homeowner renters a mortgage
market during the pandemic so this is
happening yesterday bernie sanders aoc
were out there marching i think in dc
talking about the fact that we should
extend this
there's arguments on both sides what are
your thoughts on this so
listen you want to be humanitarian and
these are properties that are owned by
the fhfa so it's it's it's not
the same as if you have some of these
eviction moratoriums that people
are faced with who are landlords and you
can see both sides of it you certainly
want to be
humanitarian in the landlord side but
you definitely want to also try and be
somewhat sympathetic to the
to the person to the person who's being
evicted i mean
both sides you could definitely see it
because a lot of people who are
landlords aren't necessarily large
corporations they're just people that
are
hardworking middle-class people they put
theirs they purchase a home because
they'd like to these are landlords
landlords
yeah you know now in this particular
case it's the fhfa
so this is a government agency here but
the moratorium that's currently in
effect for renters is something that
you want to be humanitarian sympathetic
but you also need to think about
what's that landlord going through
that's just an individual that's
purchasing that's purchased that home
and now is
is faced with somebody living there in
their home where are we at right now
with that where are we at right now with
that because if this is fhfa
it's supposed to be the end of august
that that that's been posted that's
going to be
yeah but i think that you know given
this delta variant has now
become more prevalent there's a good
chance that that gets so here's the
problem i have with that the problem i
have with it is the fact that
states were given 45 billion dollars
okay to help tenants and landlords
45 billion dollars to help tenants and
landlords okay
you know according to new york times
story that came out yesterday what
percentage of that 45 billion has been
given to tenants and landlords
do you know what percentage of 45
billion less than 20. seven percent
so here's my channel by the way this is
new york times we're not talking new
york post right now it's new york
times writing this so this is a new york
post which
some may say it's a conservative paper
so if 45 billion has been given to
states
to give to tenants and landlords and
that money hasn't gone to them
and you want to extend you can't tell me
to extend it if you're
hanging on to the money that you're
supposed to help me out to
if you give me the money i'll sit there
and say okay fine but if you're hanging
on to the money and only giving seven
percent of the 45 billion which is only
three
billion dollars what are you going to do
with this what's their justification
what's their job
because they can't what are you going to
tell me you're going to write a negative
review on yelp
you're going to go out there and yell
and there's some people that would good
luck with the government nobody go to a
government place and say you're going to
write a negative review on
something and see what they tell you
that money is not coming to you so in a
situation like this
at what point do you say listen
you guys got to figure something out i
can't keep extending this
uh i think the unemployment if you
remember the unemployment during obama
it kept extending
you know six months and it won nine
months and then it went 12 months and it
kept going extended
yeah it was a long time that it kept
going it was nearly you know 24 months
is where it got to i think 99 weeks was
the number right and
the moment you stopped unemployment
benefits guess what happened to people
the moment you stopped they go back to
work you know there's something
interesting about
that i know it's one of the stories you
want to cover but this is a really
interesting thing right now there's 9.2
million job openings
and people are pointing to that and the
fed's pointing to that this kind of lead
us into the fed as well
but the fed's saying you know we're not
seeing maximum employment well if you're
paying people 18
an hour to stay home guess what they're
going to stay home but there's an
interesting phenomenon that takes place
so half the states roughly have now said
we're going to end this additional
benefit
and what they've seen is something
that's fascinating
the number of job creations goes up but
so does the unemployment rate
so people are scratching their heads
they point to the employer and said oh
it's not really a benefit
well what happens is is when you don't
look for a job for four weeks
you are now a discouraged worker so you
literally do not get
counted as unemployed as soon as you
come off that you start looking for a
job
you start off as unemployed but so your
unemployment numbers worsen initially
but you at the same time have some of
those people who find jobs
so if you have 10 people go back five
found a job
now you have five people that are
counted as unemployed it actually makes
the unemployment
numbers look worse while jobs are being
created look better
but it depends on what side you're on
what you want to point to you always
look you always find what you're looking
for so if you point to job creations
that things are good
but eventually as these people then come
back to
finding a job and getting a job the
unemployment number should come down
so labor day we're supposed to see an
end to this additional benefit
so i'd imagine you'll probably see the
unemployment rate in september and maybe
in
october get worse while jobs are created
but then it should start to catch up and
you should
see it going past september i i
you know the delta variant is something
that people are very concerned about you
know everybody's talking about
masks indoors and this and that and i
think facebook today said they're
requiring all employees whether you're
vaccinated or not to have a mascot
don't really quite understand that um
but it's something that
individuals are are going to be faced
with now going back to work or child
care based on this and it might
it might kick the can down the road it
might prolong it you saw lindsey graham
today
did you see lindsey graham's tweet today
lindsey graham who said i took the
vaccine
uh i went and got it and i still got
covered so he's got covered right now
lindsey graham
you're hearing a lot of story here part
b to that that was part b today he said
had i not got vaccinations it would have
been what i would have been much worse
situation than where he is no
listen here's a part of what you just
said i sent kai an article this morning
from the economist kai if you want to
pull it up from the economist
showing percentages of uh what do you
call it people who are taking the jab
and this is how the economist not yeah
they go
the the econ econ not economists the
economist
there we go okay good click on that okay
so here's a story that came out from the
economist today
uh it says uh it says a fourth wave of
cove and 19 infections washing across
america thanks to delta varian
yes vaccinations have stalled that on
155 million or 60 percent of american
adult population why using polling from
yougov
and demographic profiles of 24 000
americans our data journals have built a
statistical model to estimate how likely
each respondent
is to say they have received or will get
their jab
it reveals that the single greatest
predictor of whether an american has
been vaccinated or
is whether they have voted for joe biden
or donald trump last november mr biden
supporters are 18
more likelier to get the job than those
who voted for trump that's what you're
looking at blue
vaccine hesitant the democrats believe
it or not there's still a percentage of
democrats that don't want to get the
vaccine
vaccine hesitant independents are the
biggest one there that are
percentage-wise republicans are the
biggest not sure democrats are still
by the way i would have thought not sure
democrats would have been a lot smaller
look how big democrats is three times
independence gets a little smaller uh
quite frankly republicans not sure
decreases a little bit but democrats not
sure
triples right there do you see that adam
how that looks like the
3x and then vaccinate it or demo what
does that
tell us i think that has less to do with
the politics and it has more to do with
the
proclivity towards individualism you
have people on this side that tend to be
more group oriented follow the leader
you have this side who tend to be more
you know civilly disobedient
individualistic i i think that this has
less to do with the political
proclivities
and it has more to do with what your
natural i hear you but i also think it's
both
yeah what about people that don't
believe anything that that fauci says
based upon his track record
how can you at this point yeah by the
way a good story came out from usa today
pull up the usa today's story let's just
go into that because
the usa today story i mean usa today
would you say that say
left center right where would you put it
i would say you and i
they call themselves fair and ballot so
that's pretty far left
okay so let's say they don't think
they're far left at all actually not
you know center left they're they're
elitist liberal
city liberals kai and that's the story i
think it's on the last page okay
the covet culture war if you pull up
that article it's called the covet
culture
at what point should a person should
person's freedom
uh yield to the common good usa today's
story after more than 18 months of
pandemic
with one of every 545 americans killed
that's less than
uh uh two percent killed
two tenths of a percent killed by covet
19 a substantial chunk of the population
continues to assert their own
individual liberties over the common
good this great divide
spilling into workplaces school
supermarkets and voting booths
has split the nation at a historic
juncture when partisan function
uh factional uh factionalism and social
media already achieving similar ends it
is a phenomenon that perplexes
sociologists
legal scholars public health experts and
philosophers causing them to wonder at
what point should individual rights
yield to the public interest
if coronavirus kills one in a hundred
would that be enough to change minds
what if 110. no matter where one stands
it puts a new spin on the famous line
delivered at america's founding by
patrick henry
give me liberty or give me death so at
what point by the way one in 545. if you
remember
at first when kovit came out they said
the r naught score is two percent
which means two percent two to five
percent if you remember the original
number was
closer to five percent then they brought
it down to two and a half percent and
two percent and one percent that was
that get the die of covert or what no
are not is how many people would would
contract it that you come into contact
who wrote that who wrote that
usa today okay you want to know whatever
that author is
all right shame on you
to frame it in that manner can you pull
up the article
in total tell me why tell me why though
this idea that people
haven't already done everything possible
to keep their neighbors safe
that they didn't shut down their
businesses that they didn't shut down
their schools that they didn't stay
inside their house
that they didn't completely and totally
sacrifice their lifestyle and livelihood
for a year and a half
for the benefit of the common good and
now this this [ __ ] is out here trying
to be like well what will it take
for people to give up their civil rights
but what would it take what do you mean
let me ask you a question yeah let me
let me let me ask you a secondary
question at what point can i say no
i would say i said yes we already gave
up our salary
said yes to shutting down the business
yeah i said yes to leaving my home
i said yes to staying inside at what
point am i allowed to say
no let's use this article as an example
you answer these questions
right now if the chrono virus kills one
in 100 do you get the vaccine
one in a hundred yeah if it's killing
one in a hundred okay
everybody is on def com if it kills one
in one hundred
everybody stays inside we're in the
vaccine then
at one in one hundred people confirmed i
am in a hazmat suit
okay so you get the backside i don't
touch anything i don't trust the vaccine
so you get the
adjustments what about one in ten do you
get the vaccine it doesn't dude you're
missing the point it could be one and
two i don't trust that the vaccine
no matter what i mean i'm just trying to
understand something
you have no idea what this vaccine does
and doesn't do you're blindly trusting
nobody does but wait
nobody shows up why do you
say that why do you not trust me it's
not even dude we're six months seven
months into it
most r d on these things take five to
seven years
you have no clue anybody who says they
have a clue about the long-term
ramifications this is completely and
totally full of [ __ ] and where'd you go
to medical school just to be clear where
did you go to medical i didn't i'm not
saying i'm just saying so
no no if that if you're going to try to
do an appeal to authority where did you
go to him i didn't i haven't got the
vaccine yet but if i'm so that's what
i'm saying but i'm
how do you talk about where did i go one
in a hundred [ __ ] is that where did
you go to medical school
i didn't go to medicine i'm not trying
to be an authority i'm not asking
anybody you're trying to be i'm not
telling you to stick something in your
body that you don't want
i agree with you on that so what i'm
saying where are you getting off trying
to tell me where i come back
here's my question one in a hundred or
one in ten you're going to say you're
gonna have a good
let me ask you a question let me ask you
a question though let's let's go there
because here's what i believe here's
what i believe and i'm just being very
uh uh uh uh blunt with you guys i don't
look by the way just so you know who
this dennis wagner guys and then i'll
tell you what i believe about this click
on dennis wagner
just so you know who he is the guy who
wrote it his profile is going to be on
the left
i'm a vintage ball investigative
reporter usa today with him 45 is a
journalist from under my but most
arizona public it's a vocation that
allowed me to fly to us mexico border
for pulitzer
winning project on the wall and to break
the nationwide scan on veterans
healthcare along the way also to attract
terrorists who won 9 11 attacks covered
a
apache sunrise ceremony confronted mafia
hitman samuel gravano flew combat
support mission over iraq in an era of
fake news i strive for integrity i hope
the real information we gather
uh i have a wife dog grandchildren
lifelong glove affair with wilderness
all of them
humanity god great so that's him right
okay here's a point you wanna know who
he was now you know who he is but
this is my concern let me tell you what
this is who is this guy
he's he's a guy that's not he's the guy
that wrote this article yeah this is oh
this is so based on that is he still
shame on him no no i'm not being
sarcastic
let me make my point let me make my
point i i have a sincere question for
you
yeah i have a sincere question for you
so
right now we are spending trillions of
dollars in our u.s military
trying to fight wars the way it was 5 30
years ago is that a fair assessment it
is
we're not necessarily spending the
military you know u.s
tax dollar trying to fight wars of 10
years from now we're trying to fight
wars of
30 years ago okay you highlighted this
on the basis that so so that's one
challenge that we have okay so
let's go you always have to figure out a
way to estimate what your enemy is doing
and out maneuver them
five 10 15 moves right okay we know what
china's spending money on right now what
are they spending money on they're
spending money on
figuring out ways on how to do cyber
attacks which is cyber warfare is
biowarfare bio those two right there so
just go to those two
cyber warfare biowarfare article came
out yesterday saying the fact that this
was a man-made
uh a virus built in wuhan and this is
not a
article from uh breitbart this is not a
daily caller this is not a this is an
article that was written that's saying
hey this most likely
came out of this wuhan lab great by the
way here's the part to be thinking about
this virus was deadly but it wasn't that
deadly
okay i'm not trying to be sarcastic here
it was not as deadly as
now let's see and that's with all due
respect to anybody that didn't catch it
and everything like that
absolutely please we have people that
died in the in the company we have to
pay policies
they were talking about five percent
they were talking about five percent so
i'm talking
how many people have we lost to
cigarettes in the world last year eight
million people
we lost in the world last year to
cigarettes eight million okay that
that's a real number eight million out
of eight billion
okay so but let's go back to this
question i got for you here's a question
for you
may i say one other thing let me wrap
this up and i want to make the point i
want to hear from you so say advance
let's just say we go five years from now
10 years from now 20 years from now
what what is advancement advancement
means what you get better you make
better weapons
what if these guys over there create a
weapon
that is a you know cyber
not cyber warfare bio warfare and it's
not five percent it's not
0.2 percent what if it is deadlier what
if it is 20
what if it is 30 what if it is 50 my
answer is not even about vaccine
i don't even go to vaccine dude you
don't even have time for vaccine at that
point like if this is not
hey let me go fight off the vaccine this
is about how do you play defense against
it so what is it you have tanks tanks
are not going to do [ __ ]
do you think you have enough time even
when they were saying fauci was saying
it's going to take 18 months to get this
vaccine to be ready and trump was saying
what we're going to get ready by how
many months nine months remember how he
kept saying that and voucher would say
18 months trump would say nine months
you remember that
right you're not shaking your head
saying yes man trump didn't get any
credit for the good stuff that he did on
that
my question isn't but say nine months
what the hell is nine months so so so
the point is
my my mind goes to the u.s military
needs to toughen up their bio warfare
defense mechanism and we are weak today
if somebody truly was an ugly
dirty human being that wanted to truly
destroy the world they could do it today
because the math
has been shown that this one drug this
one virus called
covet if i can make it even more
infectious what could happen so
the conversation is not going to be this
guy writing about the fact that one in
545 would you take the vaccine if it's
one in a hundred or one and ten or one
and two
that's not the conversation my
conversation is bigger than that what
are we doing as military generals
what are we doing as the leaders that
are sitting behind closed doors talking
are we having those conversations
that's the real question i would be
thinking about not this
the article to write to get people to
debate over the fact that why are you
not taking a vacation why are you not
taking a vaccine
and why you should take the vaccine
because the percentage would be higher
so persuading you to take it because in
reality
how much research have we gotten i don't
know much research
even even fauci said it's going to take
a long time to research to test to do
this to do that to do this
even the experts said that to us so yeah
there's a challenge here where people
are being questioned on both sides you
walk and chew gum at the same time i'm
not being sarcastic yes i agree with you
we should obviously prepare for
something five ten years down the road
but we can also address what's going on
right now and i gotta be honest with you
i have not got vaccinated hear me out
bro i had covet
okay i'm doing my own research my own
research
i agree individual liberties you have
the right to do what you want with your
body
i'm hearing way better arguments from
the vaccinated side
versus the unvaccinated side and
pertaining to what just everything i'm
doing a lot of research it's my own
research whatever i'm looking at
whatever i'm hearing
from what i'm hearing on the vaccinated
side like even lindsey graham came out
said today
had i not gotten vaccinated i would have
gotten way sicker how did you know that
look bro i mean how did you know that
and lindsey graham's not my guy how
much is he is he a father that's not my
point how could he possibly know i would
have gotten
the point that i'm hearing again not
vaccinated so i'm not arguing with you
bro i'm bringing up a point
what i'm hearing from the unvaccinated
are you vaccinated by the way i'm
vaccinated okay you're vaccinated it's a
personal choice cool i believe in it
cool personal choice hear you and i
agree and i agree if i
also agree with you if you're like look
but what i'm hearing from the
unvaccinated side is
i can do what i want cool respect
individual liberties and there's not
enough evidence out there
what i'm hearing on the vaccinated side
where are you at
as far as what as far as taking a shot
i'm getting closer to
thinking about it i'm getting closer
point is yeah i was at the center i'm
like i had covet bro
it was a three out of ten yeah you know
um
it was bad but not that bad you know
i've had the flu before
now i'm thinking i don't know should i
take it should i not take it i'm
listening to arguments on the right
saying don't do it don't do it i'm
making ours in the left you better do it
you better do it
and i'm being an independent thinker
much like you are and i'm hearing better
arguments
to get vaccinated versus not get
vaccinated
i don't like what we just classified as
right and left on this it's really
individual there's a lot of people
look well it is right or left i don't i
don't think it is i don't think it is to
be honest are you talking we just
hold on you know there's a great there's
a great book called in april you're
talking about trump the president took
the vaccine in april there's a crime
he's going to die of cloven because he's
overweight and he had coveted right yeah
well no
no no that's your argument though
there's a great book called how to live
i don't think he was going to take the
vaccine if he if he was
no no the point i'm trying to make i i
agree with him this is not a right and a
left thing when it comes down to the
vaccine
oh i mean i i look at the stats you can
just show that that's exactly
that's called identity politics that i'm
showing you of course i'm showing it
because it's a conversation we just had
a good conversation about it
the audience is listening and they can
make a decision for themselves
but i'm i'm seeing a lot of people
who are on the right taking it this is
not a
left right middle i'm assuming they are
older or unhealthier i don't see a lot
of young
healthy people on the right getting the
vaccinations are young healthy people
getting sick
no you're right but what the [ __ ] would
they take medication
the argument for that the argument for
that is that i know about that whether
or not
they could get deathly ill or not is
will they transmit it to
others and it seems that the evidence is
that you're less likely to transmit if
you're vaccinated so it's not just a me
thing it's like
who are my family who are the people
that i'm around what are the lifestyle
activities that i want to do so you just
you can't just think
my grandma's like i don't want to see
you because you're not vaccinated
a lot of stories about that this is my
grandma i'm like i can't see my grass
they're like no
i'm like holy crap yeah my grandma's 90
years old i can't see my grandma now
look adam here's the thing i think
everybody needs to do their own research
on i researched everyone is very
well no you're wrong i don't think
everybody is i think people just listen
to the headlines and they say i'm not
going to do it because there's crap in
this vaccine that's going to make real
so look there's evidence that there are
long hauler
issues if you contract this thing and
then there are potential issues that if
you get the vaccine too we're not saying
that either one is perfect
but for me i went really deep and
researched messenger rna i did not want
any other vaccination except for the
moderna or the pfizer because i believe
in the in the science
i've heard similar things that johnson
johnson's horrible people are people are
going to think i'm full of it but this
is the god's honest truth my mother's
best friend's son died 33 years old he
was an rn
he got the vaccine three days later died
now
could be anything could they couldn't
look correlation
is not causality i get it or causality
is not uh correlation
fine whatever uh maybe it was an anomaly
guy had a heart attack at 33
died rn in good shape okay so it's
horrible
i'm not saying all right that that one
is connected to the other
it just seems oddly strange with the
timing seems oddly strange
that hank karen died days after it's
oddly strange
and i don't trust and this is the god's
honest truth i do n
they are too invested in a narrative
right now i do not trust the numbers
that we're getting
okay so it makes it hard when we talk
about do the research and trust the
science bro
i cannot because i can't ascertain
what is real and what is not from what
we're getting from our government well
to add to what you're saying a little
bit
too much gray area right to add to what
you're saying a lot of the deaths that
you're seeing when they report like 51
and 545 who contracted die
a lot of the deaths because of the
financial arrangements within hospitals
were marked as cova deaths even though i
know people within hospitals that have
told me this they're blocking quality
that's covered and dying with kovis
that's correct
two completely different things that's
right perhaps they had it they died from
something
else but they were all coveted deaths
yeah and even somewhere they didn't even
know they put cover deaths because the
hospitals
it's a financial well let me tell you to
that because 39 000 if they get on a
ventilator 18 18 000 if they come back
you have the flu and you get diagnosed
with covid 18
000 per patient no questions asked so
there's a
financial application two quick stories
and then we'll move on i
similar to your friend that rn respect
that's horrible
i also have a friend nightlife guy dj in
miami pretty healthy guy
35 died of covet just got covered
died straight up 35 not fat not
disgusting not overweight
35 died secondly to your point i deal in
uh life settlements which is basically
based on life expectancy we get life
expectancy reports
on people mrs smith she's 82 years old
she's got diabetes she's got this
we got a life expectancy report she was
expected to live between 70 and 90
months that's how it works they give you
a range
70 to 90 months okay we had multiple
reports
two reports she's going to live you know
five six seven eight years whatever it
is
got kovit died in two weeks so did she
die of covid did she die with covid
we had a life expectancy report that
showed she'd live another
six seven years got coveted died in two
weeks she was on it
no she wasn't on a motorcycle bro she
died she was in bed
she died in a freaking hospital but
that's the thing about this i don't know
there's no there's no there's no there's
no universal answer that there are some
things that are going on on the margins
on each side that's why this is such a
hotly debated issue but go back to two
things that's why i think what's really
important in individuals
but there's two things two things that
we can all agree on and i and
that was a bad joke and i do apologize
to her and her family the
the two things we should agree on and it
goes back to what you said before okay
about how in this moment what can we
learn and what can we do because if if
we are going to be so beholden
to somebody else not being crazy and
killing all of us that's a horrible way
to live our life
one of the things i'm a supply side guy
i'm a free market guy
and this has made me re-evaluate my
thinking on on economic freedom
because there's just no way no matter
how much cheaper it is
that we should be outsourcing ninety
percent
nine zero percent of our pharmaceuticals
outside this country china i think
seventy eight percent and the other
twelve percent come from 100 agreement
there's no way and there's no for sure
they can have one bad batch of heart
medication and kill 50 million people
like that all right so i was wrong in my
ideology as far as that's concerned
it doesn't matter that it's cheaper it
doesn't matter that it's more efficient
that's why is that a supply-side guy
that's a clear and present danger to the
united states of america that is a clear
and present danger to our
our well-being as a nation we need to
bring
our pharmaceuticals specifically here we
have to be making manufacturing and
distributing
life-saving medication within our shorts
that's number one
number two all right and people don't
want to hear this and it's amazing to me
that we've gone 18 months and nobody has
said anything about this
all right but who's going to hold china
accountable
they owe everybody a lot of money and
they owe people
restitution for the lives that they've
ruined and nobody
in our government has the balls to even
bring it up yeah
so listen that that is a completely
different conversation here we just talk
a bunch of different things here you
said your point you said your points
look
if a person you know selective hearing
works for all of us
uh if you're somebody that's say a a
person that doesn't want to take it
because of your civil liberties you're
like listen don't impose it on me
you're going to probably tell stories of
people that took the vaccine and
something happened to them because your
mind
automatically is turned on and attracted
to those stories
it's just how we're why we have to
understand this question this is just
yeah confirmation bias we're all guilty
of it so for you
adam's automatically only going to tell
the stories of yeah but lindsey graham
did you know what he said afterwards if
i didn't have it
okay so then that's where he goes
because he's trying to find information
to validate why he ought to
take the vaccine more power to him it's
his choice you want to do it i i clearly
said that
i'm listening to both sides but the
stories then you said is you told the
story of a friend i was 35 years old
healthy dj miami boom
he died because of covet right so your
brain is going to those stories it's
going through stories to help you
but i also told the story of that i got
covered and i didn't get that it's a
counter-argument right so what i'm
saying
i'm only saying guys both of you guys
just did it stop we're all doing it i'm
not pointing finger
we're all doing this ain't nobody free
of this okay if fox is doing this yes
msm he's doing it
the hardest thing for us as human beings
to do is to see if we're being full of
[ __ ] or we're trying to like convince
ourselves of a decision just because we
want to make sure
validate that we're making the right
decision we're afraid of making the
wrong decision sometimes we ourselves
are more protective
of our own egos of being right or wrong
so we don't want to listen
that's a challenge some we all by the
way all of us are guilty of it i'm a
pretty
a big ego guy i understand what it is to
have a big ego and you struggle with
this the entire time
today the audience wins they get to make
a decision for themselves as far as
china goes
again that's where i went to my my
direction where i went to is who the
enemy is
my direction i always go to is the
long-term solution permanent fix
a vaccine to me is a band-aid it ain't
no permanent fix
it's purely a band-aid we're going to be
able to put a band-aid on this
6 12 18 months and now we're being told
every year you got to take it because
that's how you make it go away new
variance
i'm more interested in permanent
solutions
i understand temporary stuff go ahead
say a doctor's expert present debate
hash it out sit down do all that stuff
great
if there's if there's one area adam that
concerns me the most is to follow
let me tell you what concerns me the
most here's what concerns me the most if
you call adam a gerard out
on a event that took place that you want
to hash it out you say
i want to debate him live and talk to
him about it if he says no
continuously and he privately publicly
calls you up but doesn't want to sit
down with you
you know what it tells me he's hiding
something
if he says let's sit down and talk about
it you
are avoiding the conversation with them
and you're talking [ __ ] about him behind
his back
you're hiding something okay if
one side of doctors or media is not
allowing the opposing
argument to be heard what are you afraid
of there it is that's my fear
why don't you why don't you have a
debate on no entertainment i offered
paul off at
twenty thousand dollars he turned it
down there's gotta be someone that'll no
i offered everything i offered everybody
twenty thousand dollars they all turned
it down
just so that i know nobody would sit
down with rfk nobody would sit down with
doctors from the other side
you're talking about dr mike said three
times yes yes yes absolutely
i'm willing to sit down and talk to
anybody about us are you willing to sit
down and doctor rfq about it yes no you
know what youtube did
number one right now if you go on
youtube his page is already on the cover
page of youtube why he gets all these
suggested subscribers
because he's saying what they want him
to say and we're not that we we don't
get the suggested the
views that we used to get what's up
we're saying what they don't want us to
say we're having open dialogue
i simply want to know why an opposing
argument is constantly hidden that's all
i'm asking about
look do you know why when i was living
in iran why the concept of communism got
so much attention
do you know why because the shah kept
hiding it
because the shah kept arresting all the
two days the the communists
so the more he kept hiding it guess what
the youngest kept wanting to do
find out what's this all about what are
they afraid of why do people are power
so afraid of communism you know how you
beat communism here's how you'd be
communism shine light on it shine lotto
let's talk about it
bring it up let's talk about it so i
bring slavoj let's debate
i bring richard wolfe let's debate i
bring people
trash my argument destroy my argument
let's go through it and the audience
says i disagree with you pat i just
so when you are hiding an argument
to me you already showed your code
actively suppressed that's my concern
so i'm not my concern isn't going out
there and doing research back so my dad
got the vaccine
my household most people in my household
are vaccinated it's not like we're
sitting there saying oh we're
anti-disanti-debt not at all i just
simply ask one question why is the
opposing argument hidden
i don't know tell me why you don't have
an answer for why not because they're
ludicrous and they have no clue what the
hell they're talking about
you just lost the argument there's got
to be more argument than that anyways
can we move on from this and yeah real
estate okay
wanna talk about the fed i want to go to
page seven which is the fed go to page
seven adam
uh on page seven so we got a few
different things here
uh first story i'll go into is rent on
usb suburban homes is surging with
inventory type that's a bloomberg story
invitation homes inc the largest
single-family landlord in the u.s
boosted rents by eight
percent nationwide in the second quarter
as company hike prices amid strong
demand for suburban
properties the company which on more
than 80 000 homes boosts
rent by 5.8 percent on renewals
and 14 on leases signed by new tenants
whole so if your rent is two grand a
month is 22.80 now
is what it is according to a statement
wednesday the company also posted core
condos
from operations of 37 cents per share
beating the average analyst expectation
of 35 cents
for the key metric barry well this is a
big story because
when you talk about the real estate
market right now it's easy for people to
bash housing bash the real estate market
because they're talking about
the most recent numbers is 16.6 percent
appreciation on homes
unless i agree that's too hot you know
we'd love to see it come back down
but you also have to think about what's
the alternative is certainly not going
to want to pitch a tent so
if you're going to go rent your rent a
new transaction is going to have gone up
as well so it's almost keeping pace but
the big difference is is that with a
purchase
if you get a fixed rate mortgage which
is the vast vast vast majority
maybe you see your taxes go up slightly
but that's a pretty small portion of
your overall payment if your taxes went
up two percent
that's a small portion in general
probably less than one percent of your
payment
but on rents they're going up almost six
percent a year and you get hit with that
every year so over time the purchase
definitely has a lot of benefit to it
but people are really bashing the
housing market i understand that i mean
we were on last time we talked about a
lot of these things
look you have to be careful you have to
make your own decisions and different
markets are different
but in general if you go by the rules of
supply and demand
where's the new supply going to come
from to override the demand for housing
to cause prices to drop precipitously
like so many people are saying right i
mean and
where is the supply gonna come from well
that's more houses or what well here's
the thing people say okay well what if a
lot of people put their homes
on the market and sell them but where
are they going to live
you know they're probably they're going
to keep revenue neutral and
and we we talked about this last time
but you got a lot of influx of
first-time home buyers are going to come
in so
builders are going to put them up but
they just it's hard for them it's hard
to deliver because of chips with
appliances to get certificates of
occupancy
it's hard for builders because of land
and the costs that are involved
it's really tough to build a home for
less than 350 000
and that's really where the demand is
needed so it's it's not an easy
solution here but in the midst of it it
seems like home prices are going to be
pretty decently supported i don't see
this big question
and people love to compare to like the
stock market the thing of it is for me
is
i could sell a stock and be fined i
don't have to do anything
but if i sell my home there comes a
question is where am i going to live
replace it you know where where am i
going to stay now if it's an investment
property that's one thing but sure
the percentage of investors is not like
it was in 2007 2008 we had you know
one person buying several homes remember
the movie the big shorts
of course yeah yeah and a condo right so
um how's she doing by the way uh well
you know what i don't know
i lived it there for two years it was
great that's great free rest so
brian see you there friday night i got a
vote real quick story about o'brien
sorry barry
real quick story so we're at o'brien's
over here in boca raton man and then
we'll get back to
the housing but we're we're adam's
buying out the whole bar adam spent
about a thousand dollars
you're a girl you were drinking you got
a drink that night dude we were
celebrating karaoke
so there's this absolute smoke show
smoke show adam buys i don't know a
thousand dollars with the white clothes
finally gets to talking to her
and then goes comes over to me and i was
like bro did you get her number he goes
dude
i already had her number in my phone
completely forgot
that he had this girl's number so yeah
uh the biggest point of the story is he
found his
favorite bar of all time i love the
place anyway let me let me go back to
asking a question here i mean
i got a question for you about this
thank you so random story so so the 14
so the 14 so they're raising rent
on new tenants 14 existing
5.8 percent the numbers on inflation
came out last month was what 5.4 percent
and that's only a month of course rates
4.5 that's year over year
year over year yeah okay so that's on
cpi pce which the fed
likes better but it's a stupid measure
so give me the number which one is more
of a number to look at when it comes to
cpi is more accurate
four point five percent yeah four and a
half percent let's say four and a half
percent so if this
is 5.8 on existing
it's 14 on new
is this they have analysts
analysts are not going to give numbers
like this for the hell of it are the
analysts
assuming that inflation is going to go
to percentages like 14 to match it or
are they just saying
nope there's a demand we can charge this
number they're going to pay for it
okay inflation probably comes down a
little bit but this is just because
there's just too much demand
it's it's you're talking about florida
and nationally we're talking nationally
these are national numbers but really if
you go to most parts of the country it's
a similar story
there's just too much damn demand and we
don't have enough supply on the market
let me let me ask you this because
because that this is something that in
jersey city and brooklyn where i came
from like i never understood it and then
brooklyn like me nice man what part
bensonhurst nice man what's second
avenue p graves
wait a minute did you go to p.s 177 no
uh no no i went to the school right
there in dahil and avenue p west first
no i was on west seventh saint simon and
jude in new jersey okay i got you
remember when we were chilling granada
1.8 gpa me too bro so the uh this is
what i don't understand
and it was explained to me as as reits
were the problem because there are
entire blocks
there are entire blocks that stay empty
for years and they the rents never come
down so everybody heard a year ago two
years ago new york's dead
go move to new york everybody's leaving
the rents have not gone down so they
they package these things and it they
are it's okay for them to lose money
because apparently this is apparently
the scam that they do
there's like three parts of the scam all
right well it's completely legal but
it's a scam
the first thing that they do you're
you're only allowed a three percent uh
raise in in rent year over year so what
they'll do is they'll make the rent 2
500 but give you three months free
so you're you're paying you know 1900
and then the rent goes up
after a year to you know 26. then
they they take the first two floors of
these luxury high-rises and they section
eight them
so people are are getting it on
government dime they're getting they're
spending eight hundred dollars for these
twenty five hundred dollar
apartments then it's pre-paid for by the
government apparently section 8.
and then the rest of it they package
together like bizuto and all these other
real estate firms
that run these they package it together
and then they sell it on the back end
as as a reit so and that read apparently
is
x amount of units times x amount of of
average
rent per month whether they rent it or
not yeah but this is invitation homes
these are single-family homes that
they own and that they're renting out
these are real numbers okay yeah this is
not a scam imputation homes is the
largest landlord in the united states
and these are all single-family homes so
they're very representative of what's
really going on in the world
if if so why why is rent staying
stagnant
it's not it's going up fourteen percent
yeah yeah that's what then
there's nobody buying homes people are
buying homes there's
there's a ton of people buying homes in
fact when you look at the numbers you
have to be careful like the mortgage
bankers association last week
they come out with this story they got
so many headlines and it said purchase
applications year over year are down 18
first of all 18 from a feverish pace
secondarily
what they don't do and this is why you
got to be careful with statistics and
you have to go deep
most people don't when you take a look
at the numbers
mortgage applications means you took out
a mortgage to buy a home
well what about people that paid cash a
year ago 16
of individuals paid cash the recent
numbers it's almost
24 so there is a drop but it's not 18
it's 9 but inventory is 20 less prices
are 16
higher there's less available so yes
they're going to be less transactions
happening but these are off of very very
high numbers
you have to differentiate real estate in
two parts one is real estate the driver
of gdp
and how many transactions are generated
and then there's real estate if i buy a
home
will i make money on it or lose money on
it if i make money or lose money on it
right now
it's difficult to buy a home it's a
lousy time to buy a home
but if you do it the benefits are really
really great and then you have to think
about why
why is it why did you say it's allows
you to it's awful to buy a home right
now because
you have to likely bid over asking price
you have a very difficult time because
of lack of inventory
sellers are going to dictate terms and
often times but
it's kind of like look it also sucks to
diet it also sucks to work out sometimes
right
but you do it because the benefits are
good and when you think about this this
is not about perfect it's about choice
where am i going to live am i going to
live in a home that i own or am i going
to live at home
what is the opposing argument to what
you just said so play the devil's
advocate play
argue your own argument in your own
world you're in your world how do you
argue what you just said
it's very difficult to argue against it
if you understand the numbers because
where am i what
if i believe that the housing what is
the drug common arguments what are the
common arguments
the argument is home prices are going to
drop because they went up okay
that's about that and so what if they
say renting i'll stay safe renting
and this way i'll be in a position where
if home prices drop i've benefited by
that right so
renting is it's not the same as on the
sidelines because you're still paying to
put a roof over your head whereas
that could be giving you some of that
towards principle and then the question
is appreciation right
so it's it's hard to argue against it
once you start to see what the facts are
if you believe there's a housing crash
in a housing bubble
then you certainly shouldn't purchase a
home i don't believe that i think that
home prices are going to be driven
higher
so you're saying the fed is lying to us
the fed is lying to us and it's
it's uh it's very interesting because
the number that almost everybody throws
out there's how much is the fed buying
you mortgage-backed securities to keep
rates low and they say 40 billion
dollars a month that's
a month that's complete [ __ ] that's
someone like the government to lie to us
though are you sure
yeah i know right so um here's
the truth of it is they're buying more
than 100 billion dollars a month which
is an incredible number
now last year they said they were going
to buy starting march 40 billion dollars
in in mortgage-backed securities
so if you take starting in march they'll
be 10 months right so that'd be 400
billion how much they bought
2 trillion they bought 50 of the
marketplace
now this year they say they're buying 40
billion that's all you see 40 billion 40
billion they changed the language in the
fed statement very
likely to say oh at least but it's over
100 billion that they're buying this
year
for the first six months they bought 682
billion dollars
if it would have been the real if they
would have been telling us 40 billion
and done that that's only 240
billion so the thing that they're not
talking about is the reinvestment in
other words they're holding
four trillion dollars of mortgage-backed
securities as somebody refinances or
sells their home
instead of taking that money in they're
taking the same money
and buying back and they're saying we're
not going to count that i said this is
not a ridiculous argument
that's like saying don't count my food
consumption in gdp because i'm just
replacing it
if my phone breaks and i buy a new one
don't count that at gdp don't count that
as a sale because i'm just replacing it
that's a bs argument they're buying an
enorm they're buying 40
of the mortgage market right now 40 of
the mortgage market so all this talk
about tapering and is not going to
destroy housing
if they taper it's not going to be a
reinvestment they're not going to touch
that
so if they if they say they're the new
purchases of 40
if they cut it to 30 or 25 that's tiny
it's very very small it's not going to
impact let me ask you break this down
this is like the macro economics of real
estate and that's great
how does this affect the person that's
maybe considering buying a house the
bottom line considering renting the
bottom line
rates are going to fluctuate certainly
but they're not going to go way up there
in fact
i believe that rates will probably head
lower because the stimulus that we've
seen
it wears off we know this factually
stimulus it gives you a big boost it
causes a little inflation it causes
economic activity
but then what's left behind is the debt
and that debt has to be serviced and
paid
and that slows down the economy we've
seen it everywhere in the world
everywhere through time
and when you see the debt way on the
economy it drives interest rates slower
i think that the time
we live in a world of perpetual stimulus
though man i mean that's the
well that's the thing there's already a
little bit of pushback on the additional
stimulus that's going out there but
you're right that's the other argument
is do we continue to see that stimulus
and does that eventually
are they considering another stimulus
because all i hear is oh yeah always
baby
they're they're blowing on they're out
another way to take your money and put
it in their pocket but the big thing on
the agenda is the infrastructure bill
right now i'm not hearing a lot about
what do you think that is what do you
think that is but
when you look at the infrastructure bill
there's a lot of aspects of it
on the second phase that they want to do
which are nests
aren't necessarily up to a separate
structure
the balance sheet for the fed is eight
trillion dollars which is an insane
amount of money
but the levels of stimulus that we've
seen are incredible in 2020 had
2.8 trillion um in in march and april
and then you had december was 900
billion
and then another 1.9 trillion of march
is another 2.8 trillion
it's insane the amount of money what do
you do with the lenders man like
like i'm in the market right now and
they're they want no matter what
20 down and they i they're they're
telling me i don't want 20 percent i got
a lot of income and i'm like yeah i have
a lapse in income
a lot of people like everybody has a
lesson no by the way a lot of people
think that they want 20
down that's that that's a common thing
that people believe but it's not true
you can purchase a home with five
percent with three percent three and a
half percent down
there's plenty of programs available fha
loan
fha will do that but also just
conventional loans you can deal with
three percent or five percent out of you
what should gerard do
you should in my humble opinion gerard
you want to try and be careful on the
purchase i know it's not easy but i
would definitely purchase a home you
don't need 20
down and i think that you'll do well
with that over time i really
depends if you're going to be buying a
home and then selling it a year from now
that's very risky but if you're saying
like most people i'm going to buy this
home i'm going to live there for eight
or nine years
you'll probably do really really well so
residents forget investing that's that's
basically
no i wouldn't say uh investing in real
estate investors what do you mean
so from what if i can kind of uh distill
what you're saying is like okay if
you're looking for a residential
purchase now is it as good a time as
you'll get
but if you're looking for an investment
purchase you should probably kick the
can
no i think that an investment purchase
is is also a good idea as well i mean
again you have to be careful about that
but
there's a very good probability that the
value over time
will continue to do pretty well now as a
realtor would you ever tell me there's a
bad time to buy it
yeah no listen uh when when we were
inside the right question
okay so so you know you could pull up my
clips on cnbc i used to get hate mail
because i said to people do not buy home
in 2007 or don't
you know this is a risky time i didn't
like in fact i sold my company because i
did not believe
the market just didn't make sense but
that was a time where
we had demand was waning because 33
years before that
you had abortions were legalized less
first-time home buyers coming in and
builders in 2006 built more homes than
they ever built they built 2 million
homes so it's the opposite of today
you had too much demand too much supply
rather not enough demand
it was troublesome plus one person was
buying more than one home on average
whereas today the biggest thing you said
on the last time just everybody knows
you're you know barry
for some who don't know your three-time
zillow
uh what what what is a it's called what
is this
at the golden ball that's a difference
that's a vegas that's vivid this is
different this is
sell real estate crystal balls that's a
wrong connection
that's the wrong convention buddy that's
vegas convention vivid that's golden
ball this is crystal ball
predicting what's going to happen to
real estate
but one of the things he said last time
the difference between 0.708 and today
is
inventory we had 3.8 i think the number
one 7.7 million
with 116 million households that's
insane to think about
versus today it's only what do we have
right now more than a million million
forty thousand point two right now yeah
okay so supply and demand
that's a big supply but hold on now
you've got almost 130 million so you got
you know
almost 14 million more households with
almost 3 million less homes yeah
so statistically it's different data
that says
if i'm a realtor and i'm in that
business that's the argument i'd be
telling every client i'm selling a house
to
this is if you think this is a bubble
3.7 million inventory in 2007 2008
versus today's a million 42 million two
depending on what month you're on so
but let's talk about something that
really matters this is a
heartfelt story here that's going to
affect a lot of people out there
and i want people to brace for impact
bacon may disappear in california
as big rules take effect okay so this is
a little bit emotional for some people
it is suck it definitely does suck this
is an associated press story
at the beginning of next year california
will begin enforcing an animal welfare
proposition
approved overwhelmingly by voters in
2018 that requires more space for
breeding pigs egg-laying chickens and
veal calves
national veal and egg producers are
optimistic they can meet the new
standards but
only four percent of hawk operations now
comply with the new rules unless the
courts
intervene or the state temporarily
allows non-compliant meat to be sold in
the state california will lose almost
all of its pork supply
much of which comes from iowa with
little time
left to build new facilities insimin
sows and
process uh the offspring by january it's
hard to see that pork industry can
adequately supply california
which consumes roughly 15 of all pork
produced in the country
15 of all pork produced in california
california's restaurants and groceries
use 255 million
pounds of pork per month but its farms
only produce
45 million pounds a month if half
the pork supply was suddenly lost in
california
bacon prices could jump 60 percent
meaning a six dollar package
could rise to nearly 10 bucks adam i'm
going to go to you because i know this
is a little bit more closer to you so
what do you think about this
as a jew who loves bacon this is this is
this is disastrous
that's what i was thank god i live in
the free state of florida and don't have
to deal with this california bs
but something to all my uh bacon eaters
out there
check out turkey bacon i'm about to do a
commercial for turkey bacon i eat turkey
bacon
it's healthier it's not as good turkeys
don't have butts where's that bacon come
from
i don't know but i know you like big
bucks and you cannot lie gerard
but i don't know by the way on a serious
note if you run a restaurant
yeah if you're in california if you run
a grocery
and you're accustomed to needing about
million pounds of pork a month and now
it's only producing 45 million pounds
i don't think this changes behavior i
think just people pay it and all you do
is make it more expensive
so you think it's going to go up 60. i
think it goes i think it just goes up i
think it just go i think people pay it
at some point you're because because i'm
not getting the bacon but think about it
for a full pack of bacon so what is it
going to be incrementally if you want it
on your sandwich okay
what's going to cost you an extra dollar
so i'm not i'm going to pay an extra
dollar
that's what's going to happen get that
money back i don't know
look man i look california is is just
turning into like a foreign universe to
me man southern california needs to
break off do its own thing i believe in
a volunteer society anyway if they want
to go
have like this you know vegan utopia
communist uh thing that they go
have it just take it but you can't be
serious break off
that what does that mean what does that
mean drink it go for it man so
they're not a state anymore go for it
they're not they don't get all of
california they don't get all of it but
they
look man you wanna you wanna take care
are you talking about chas in uh seattle
what are you talking about go for it
guys go show the rest of us that you're
smarter
do it do it make make your citizens
happy
go show us show us go
go put together the the san andreas cup
are you a bacon guy
bacon bacon bacon bacon bacon oh come on
bacon are you
dylan loves bacon so i will eat it just
because dylan likes bacon so we'll sit
there and have bacon together
bacon egg and cheese on a sunday morning
after a night
i'm good with that i'm good with that so
that's that's the biggest that was that
that is a very heartwarming story brace
for impact yeah i wanted to shut up
because i know you were interested in
that by the way osama bin laden's family
abandoned their belarus state list for
28 million dollars have you guys seen
this house
pull up this house by the way if you
would have thought a matter of fact
before you pull
it up i got a question for you if you
would have thought the name osama bin
laden
and in a state of bel air what color
would you guess this house wouldn't be
white white what color would you say
there's no way in the world
osama bin laden barbara estate and the
color
is pink pull up the house the sister
house
type in osama bin laden house biller
okay
oh my gosh you interviewed his niece i
did not know her matter of fact we were
texting yesterday yes she's work shoes
kai in the future you can just have
these tabs ready and go right to him i'm
just saying right there click on that
click on that he normally does but this
one john cougar
by the way shout out to kai's new
haircut has anyone checked this out
that's he's he's too good looking can
you control
his stuff and make it bigger kai it's
important for people to see what this
house looks like
there it is pink i was right that's a 28
million dollar house 20 million dollar
house john cougar
if you've got to be a holdbacker if
you're thinking about it it's uh
adam not a bad idea for you it looks
like the bomb i'm good i'm good in
california
but you know as i started reading this
story i'm like hold on what there's bin
laden's that live in america
this seems really by the way let me let
me read this whole story so people get
the idea osama bin laden's
brother ibrahim bin laden has listed his
long-time baller mansion for whopping 28
million dollars ibrahim who's the older
half brother of the late terrorist has
owned the property for nearly
four decades this is a new york post
story since 1983 ibrahim purchased the
mediterranean villa style mansion for
1.65
million dollars in 1983 what would be
roughly 5.5 million
after counting for 38 years of inflation
but according to the listing he hasn't
occupied the home since 9 11 attacks
like osama ibrahim was one of 56
children born to the saudi
arabian construction tycoon muhammad bin
bin laden
yes he has 22 wives muhammad served as
the patriarch of multi-billionaire bin
laden clan a family with long-standing
businesses ties to al-saud
royals adam gohan you were saying
something yeah well look
as i started reading the story the
beginning of it i was like hold on what
the hell are you talking about osama
milan has family that lives here in bel
air what the hell like what is going on
here
no [ __ ] that he hasn't occupied the home
since september 11th
and then you don't just go with the
headlines you dig a little deeper like
you said you can't
and i said all right he's got 56
siblings 56 children from 22
concubines and all right that
that that makes it a little easier to i
mean
and i and i circle back to the interview
you did with nora bin laden
who i think is a big trump lady
it's just uh you know how they say the
apple doesn't fall from the tree
sometimes it does
i interviewed a guy yesterday i can't
wait for this interview to go live his
name is uh
uh what's his name amin i mean and he
was a former al qaeda member who became
an mi6 spy
wow i mean it's a fascinating story
brilliant guy genius of a guy was
recruited by osama bin laden he was
there at one of the meetings when osama
bin laden sold him on the vision
of what they were going to be doing he
was part of the camp he worked with them
he was a one
he was a person he he says osama bin
laden came up and he says listen
you obviously don't have what it takes
to be one of those visionary leaders
that people follow you just don't have
that
i said what osama bin told him i said
why would he say that he says because i
had glasses on and i was small and i was
weak
and he wanted people that were strong i
said okay i said so what did he say you
could do he says well he knew i was very
well read he says i think you can make
bombs for us
so he said they taught me how to make
bombs that's the story and he became an
mi6 spy for uk telling on everything he
learned
working with pretty incredible that they
kept the last name like i feel like
if you if somebody in your family does
something that atrocious i think you
just got to go ahead well you know pablo
escobar's son
uh and his wife changed their last name
and they went and lived
in argentina pablo escobar's son's name
is
pablo escobar but he changed his name to
sebastian marroquin
you're gonna have to switch that one up
yeah there's not too many made offs from
uk
or hitler's not a lot of stalin's out
there yeah it's probably not uh not a
name you want to yeah that kind of does
make sense the more i think about it you
know
phenomenal point you just made right so
my dad tells me i said that so why don't
you guys name me sasha i said my mom
wanted me sasha how did that idea come
about and she said
you ever seen the movie uh he said dr
zhivago
and in dr zhivago the communist was
sasha
my dad said never in a million years
will i name my son after communist
he named me patrick although most people
in the military told me you know your
real name is not patrick you look more
like a muhammad than a pantry
yeah i said i'm telling you it's patrick
they said you're lying to us did you get
a lot of hate in the
military of course i did but being a
middle eastern or you have to learn to
troll back
and play with them instead of being
sensitive about it great game
right there so okay let's continue let's
continue let's continue okay next story
wikipedia should you trust them
how many of us go and look at wikipedia
you know let me see the wikipedia for
whatever it may be
so the founder of wikipedia said nobody
should trust
wikipedia says founder larry singer
says site has been taken over by
left-wing
volunteers who writes off sources that
don't fit their agenda as fake
news wikipedia can no longer be trusted
as a source of unbiased information side
the online encyclopedia left-leaning
volunteers can cut
out any news that doesn't fit their
agenda according to the founder larry
singer co-founder of wikipedia in 2001
alongside with jimmy wells
said the crowdsourcing project has
betrayed its original mission by
reflecting the views of the
establishment he said
he agreed with the assessment that the
team of democratic leaning voters
volunteers remove content that isn't to
their liking including information about
scandals
linked to joe biden and his son hunter
when asked if wikipedia can be trusted
he replied
you can trust it to give a reliably
establishment point of view on pretty
much
everything okay that's that's his
comment how many guys actually use
wikipedia actually
i do i do yeah i use i i use wikipedia i
think it's a uh
uh you know decent place to go to
you know see what they have to say i
don't know about how much of this stuff
they take off but i think a lot of
people but i don't use it for any
political reasons i just look i look at
it for who was
or they're running like pr for certain
people and certain things and it is
constantly updated you can throw snopes
in the same thing and that
you can throw the facebook fact checkers
in there it's all you know i i get
uh i get a strike against me on facebook
like every every full moon
so like two weeks i get a strike against
me on facebook and then i go in and i
see which fact checker
says that i broke some sort of rule and
almost
100 of the time it's somebody that
doesn't exist in real life they they
have they they come from beijing
mostly and that you can follow them you
you click in you gotta
you gotta have no time on your hands
like i do and you go in and you click
and you say okay who did this they show
you who it is and then you look at the
articles that they've written and
everything like that and it's
it's it's like it's straight out of the
ccp
straight out of it it's straight
propaganda so well i have a question on
this wikipedia because this is the first
thing that came to mind the left
leaning volunteers that's what the
article says right so they're not paying
people
oh no the volunteers writers are
volunteers all volunteers 100
so if you're concerned that it's too
left-leaning get some
right-leaning volunteers there's a
system for it but but you know there's a
system
is there a tummy yeah there's a system
for who
has enough scoring to be able to write
and you know typically people who are
unemployed have more time to write
is this going to make you distrust going
on wikipedia like i'm still going to
like
let me ask you a question do you have
time to work for wikipedia of course
do you have time to go up there and help
them out all the time gerardo how you
doing man you're going to go help them
write stuff up man
i'm i'm here to fight the culture or
after i get off of work with you at 11.
i'll go
right typically whoever has the most
time
can ride alone but you know it is scary
though it is scary to think about a
resource that a lot of us use and depend
on could be
slanted like that or where it's where
it's revisionist where they will
remove or edit things just but isn't
that history in a nutshell
yes so whoever wins the war this is the
new right this is the new religion adam
i'm telling you that just like
not new though is my point no no this is
this like leftist religion that
this is taking over the judeo-christian
perspective that we all grew up in
but you're right it's not new but it is
much more um
able to be reached by everyone so
quickly you know it can have much more
of a dramatic and immediate impact so
it's much more powerful than it used to
be because
you know bridges can on their phone or
whatever and seconds go there but this
circles back to what pat said before
it's one thing to put that
there and that's fine you have your
perspective no problem
the problem becomes when you start
silencing or suppressing
or banning any counter perspective
that's the issue that's the hard line in
the sand
that's this whole like we talked about
oftentimes well it's both sides it's
both sides
yes it is to a degree except in
application
right because right now if you have a
counter perspective to the
the establishment they will silence you
they will digitally throw you in a gulag
they will take your page down
they will they will suppress your views
they will shadow ban you
they will do everything they possibly
can to limit
your ability to expose your perspective
to the masses while
amplifying the perspective that that
they want to promote but this goes back
to pat's point that if he ever
ran a school the academy vault academy
you would have two teachers
i'd never have left leaning teacher on a
right i would do it like
you two would be teachers for me you
guys would be teaching one class
oh wow because what would happen no
because think about it first of all you
like each other
you guys go party together and you get
numbers of girls you already numbers
have that's what you guys do and you
spend a thousand dollars at bars by the
way
once you announce what bar are you going
to be this week so people can show up
because apparently you're buying for
everybody
what night shout out give the night
eight nights a week
me and the beatles saturday night week
saturday night i'm actually going to be
uh sleeping in saturday because some of
us are going to vegas
who's this weekend well aren't you going
to vote
[Laughter]
this guy's throwing the biggest party of
his life what's going on
no no no no we're going to be that's
right nikki jam we've got sebastian
monasco
we got mario lopez we'll be hosting mike
tyson frederick the civil all next week
what's your favorite
nicki jam song it's the main one what's
the one it's x
it's the it's uh that's it yeah that one
it's only that that's the main song dvd
gets you going when you listen to it
okay i just saw sebastian's new show
it's really good sebastian's a
flip and stud you know why because the
guy is
he comes across as a guy that's an
introvert quiet to himself he kind of
wants to be left alone
the guy's got strong opinions and he's
an absolute genius of a guy his
brain you can see goes a million miles
an hour can i give a shout out to a
friend is that okay sure
okay if you guys want if you like
sebastian maniscalco i got a buddy of
mine
that's in the new york comedy scene back
home and his name is jason
scoop and he does the single greatest
sebastian maniscalco impression of all
time wow
of all time check out jason jason scoop
yeah s-c-o-o-p if you're all right
check out him on tick-tock or or uh
instagram you'll love his trump and
you'll love his uh
he's in him while we're giving shout
outs can i give him a quick shot no no
more let me know
i'm doing it doing it i don't care
grandma go ahead grandma i love you
i'm giving a shout out to someone that's
very beloved to all of us
it's her birthday miss nancy tran hey
okay
she's here in the office happy birthday
that's our girl by the way
yeah it was george palaio's birthday it
was chris phelps the birthday and it's
radolf of vargas's birthday
so today this last week they all have
birthdays around the same time
50. well we can't give a shout out to
him because it's a little shout out to
nancy
he wants no one to know he turned 50 and
you just told
people he turned 50 greg think greg just
turned 41.
okay let's continue let's continue let's
continue all right so
trump story comes out man apparently
this guy's running
trump is moving forward a 2024
presidential election uh run
in a real way and is meeting with the
cabinet members at his new jersey golf
club
former chief of staff says
uh page eight i know adam you're fully
surprised that he's running this is a
business insider story
former president donald trump met with
the cabinet members at trump national
golf club
in bedminster new jersey to discuss his
political future according to his former
chief of staff mark meadows meadows a
loyal ally to the former president
further teased the potential trump run
the meeting revolved around
what comes what does come next meadow
says i'm not authorized to speak on
behalf of the president
but i can tell you this meadow said we
wouldn't be meeting tonight if we
weren't making plans to move forward in
a real way
with president trump at the head of the
ticket the former president has
confirmed that another presidential run
is a real possibility in april he said
that he is 100 percent thinking about
running again i don't know if he said
he's 100 thinking about running again i
think sean hannity asked
have you already made up your mind what
you want to do he says i've already made
up my mind what i'm going to do but he
didn't say
what that meant so having said that are
you still in the same place he's running
oh i've said it
100 i believe nothing's changing in your
mind listen i have a rule of thumb that
i've lived by for the past year
whatever tom zenner says whatever
prediction
go the opposite route he predicted
trump's not running
he's running yeah he predicted would
never win
he predicted 100 percent of that sports
is actually doing good
yeah i actually enjoy dominant on
valuetainment sports predictions
but tom is actually he actually the last
podcast i did with tom on the sports
channel
he asked me to do it and i appreciate it
thanks tom he actually said no no the
milwaukee never won they they didn't win
i giannis i'm like what are you talking
about
he goes no no you know i didn't really
win
what world are we living in here so
anyway i do 100 percent think that trump
is going to running i think he i do i
think he's playing the round
he's going to run oh man now here's the
question he's going to run does he get
primaried
door they do they roll up is a
republican party but dude he's holding
the party
there's nobody wait a minute i think
there's a couple of good there's a
couple of good possibilities whether
they run or not
people are going to want to position
themselves as the answer give me someone
who
actually in the republican party can
beat trump how about you how about the
santa claus
zero how about the senator he'll be his
vp so by the way
the other day i'm outside playing with
the kids a yacht comes by
okay huge biden flag
would you imagine it was a flag that
said trump desantis 2024 yeah
because they are both domiciled in
florida and apparently
look this up fact check it you can't run
if you're both from the same state
i don't know if that's just or
sure or you know whatever i'm just
saying that that's
the same ticket from the same that's
what i understand yeah maybe that
that actually might be true but okay um
so yeah i'm just gonna go back to new
york and do that
that's in new york it's a clerical issue
man i mean that's yeah i still think
he's running whether it's the santa well
let me
did you guys hear the story i hope he
doesn't really beating trump because i'm
trying to fill out the article i just
sent you from the hill
you guys hear the story about megan
mccain and what she said about
desantis and kamala did you hear those
comments no did you hear about it so did
you hear about it or no
megan mccann yesterday was asked about
what would happen because they're
already thinking pbs is a big view fan
by the way for people that don't know uh
uh big die hard so megan mccain
said she was asked about the idea of
what would happen if kamala harris
was to replace biden which that's kind
of how the conversation was going
kai did you get the story i just sent
you if kamala harris were to replace
biden
could desantis beat kamala harris
in a debate so she is lobbying for who
desantis right if he can mute that guy
if you can megan mccain is at the same
time
okay go lower go lower go lower go lower
so harris's approval rating linked to
immigration stands the co-host reacts to
several polls that found vice president
kamala hirsch has the lowest approval
rating of any president vice president
since the 70s lowest ever i know you're
fully surprised by it but it's the
lowest no i'm not
why are you not surprised by it i just
don't think she's that great
she got smoked in the primary by her own
chamber
she made history by being a first female
she did make history yeah
that is true you're not impressed by her
as a vp i'm not that impressed no why do
democrats even bother with primaries at
this point like they they just rig them
for who they want anyway just tell us
who it is like why are you
making mccain megan mccain on monday
predicted that florida governor desantis
would put vice president kamala hurst in
the ground if they were to face off
against each other
in a presidential election i think she
stumbled when she was running for
president she dropped out before iowa
she was a very early dropout she wasn't
resonating with voters
way before president biden was elected
mccain said
acknowledging that she could not be
unbiased due to being a
republican okay so there you have it i
don't know see
gabbard absolutely she saddened her
mccain criticized harris has approached
immigration crisis that she's been
tasked with handling pointing out that
she
laughed off questions about visiting the
border her laugh has become a way for
people to take hits at her because it's
uncomfortable to watch it's
uncomfortable to answer and she
i always thought she needed more media
training than she had
the problem with democrats going into
2024 is if president biden chooses not
to run
for re-election she's just not going to
be a strong enough candidate to run for
president ron desantis
would uh put her in the ground i mean it
would be an election for republicans
republicans would love nothing more than
to run against
vice president kamal do you agree with
her how much longer can they go to the
you're a racist or a sexist if you don't
vote for me war chest
we've got what 12 16 years of this do
you think they can make a 20-year run on
i mean they're still if if mid-years
becomes as catastrophic as a lot of
people think it's going to be mid
midterms not mid-year if midterms
becomes as catastrophic as a lot of
people predict it's going to be
it's going to be very hard if she is the
front-runner to win but here's the other
question for you
complete change it up megan uh making
mccain
can you see her ever doing anything with
politics
you can't i can because she's got name
recognition but i don't think she would
would she do anything other than liz
cheney just walk in under the
the the establishment banner and and you
kind of like the way she handles herself
on on when she's
i mean you're on a show by the way the
best training you get she plays away
games
yeah oh everybody kidding me every day
sitting across those people at the table
getting destroyed and you're the one
that you know they're going to come
after you
you're going to get stronger it's just
that's what's going to happen your
argument's going to get stronger yes you
may
understand their argument a little bit
more but your argument is going to get
strong so i think megan's got
you know she has a potential doing
something long-term i don't know if she
wants to live that life for that i just
think she's got uh she could do it
i just wonder if if media training is a
way to say
don't tell people what you really
believe do what you really believe but
don't say it publicly which is yeah
it's just a terrible way to think you
know do not come
don't do it yeah do not that became it
i'm gonna go
oh mean for a lot of people man you guys
set up
the united states okay uh next story
what story do we want to go to guys pick
a story mcdonald's earnings be driven by
new chicken sandwich and promotion with
k-pop band
frankie yes if you want to pull it up
kai pull up the story there on the
on the screen so people can see it so
mcdonald's
uh this was a model they did i think
last year sometime as well that was very
successful for the mcdonald's
report on wednesday that the chains
crispy chicken sandwich helped us
same store sales outpace 2019 levels by
double digits u.s same store sales climb
25.9 percent a quarter
and 14.9 on two-year basis the company
credited strong sales to its new
chicken sandwich which launched in
february and its famous orders promotion
with k-pops group ets
which includes an order of mcnuggets and
special sauces the fast food giant
reported fiscal
second quarter net income of 2.222
billion 2.22 billion
or 2.95 dollars per share up from a 483
million
or 65 cents per share ceo chris
kemzinski told analysts that seventy
percent of mcdonald's u.s dining rooms
have been reopened
if a covet-19 resurgence doesn't occur
all of its u.s footprints
should have opened dining rooms by labor
day
gerard thoughts on this story yeah they
i
it goes back to uh in our creative right
in creative we spend so much
time trying to be unique and original
and come up with the concept that
nobody's ever came up with
and at the end of the day there's only
seven stories and all you can do is tell
one of those
stories that's been told a million times
yeah your way so instead
mcdonald's the the harvard graduates
they were like
you know what's really popular the
popeye's chicken sandwich let's do that
that's what they did you know the war
was like popeyes and wendy's and now
they're
jumping into yeah they were like yeah
we're mcdonald's let's just do that they
made a popeyes chicken sandwich
they they made it for like a buck less
and it's it's it's all right i mean it's
pretty good
what i want and for all the
entrepreneurs out there you get this one
for free give me like one percent and
let me be the spokesperson of this all
right
why can't we have like a cauliflower
based like crouton cone like an ice
cream cone that you could put the salad
inside the cone
so we can eat healthy on the go like
i've always thought like like seaweed
wrap or something like that like you
have like the sushi dude you lost me at
cauliflower like no but instead of the
carbs bro it's no carbs so it's like
think like an ice cream cone and then
you put the dressing in there
we're gonna go have it today i wanna
have the that's not the best cauliflower
and actually gluten-free cauliflower
costs are pretty good
healthy on the go man i i thought you
were going somewhere totally different
with this story if you want to do
something different
i thought you were different i thought
you're talking about popeye chicken
sandwiches i lost you at cauliflower
yeah this is
this is um what an innovative campaign
take pop culture icons and
make commercials around the fried
chicken do you know bts's do you know
who bts is
the k-pop group you actually know who
they are yeah we looked at the picture
but it's i don't listen you know okay
they're huge they're the problems who
did they do before that travis scott one
of the biggest rappers in the world
they didn't oh just justin timberlake
they did mj obviously
and then they did bad bunny all they're
doing is taking the most famous
musicians in the world and being like i
like mcdonald's
that's where i thought you were going
with like what a genius idea i do wish
that there were laws about marketing
though where you actually had to show
like the type of people who eat your
stuff not the type of people you want
like it should it shouldn't be sexy bts
people
like it should be fat asses like it
should just be girard hungover
like four in the morning all over me
barbecue sauce all over your face
trying to get my my nuggets out of the
side while i'm driving with the left
that should be the commercial they
shouldn't be allowed
has there ever been a drunk guy in a
beer commercial it's always like people
playing volleyball looking sexy and
stuff
it should just be like you know making
love ultra hanging out with their panda
and their pants watching their eighth
hour of nfl sunday football
yeah no that's exactly you guys you guys
get that out of your system that was
good that was very nice exchange right
there with
uh trying to get the job as a mcdonald's
cmo they're probably not going to hire
you
maybe they might they might take that uh
but the local burden
is looking for cmo did i ever tell you
my first job ever was as burger king it
was in glendale california
and i it was my first job i worked at
valley what was your first job
first job uh what was your first job
buried i worked in a butcher store
believe it or not really yeah i worked
in a butcher's jersey or
in brooklyn new york in brooklyn new
york yeah i learned yeah learned a lot
about the meat business very cool
the slogan was you can beat our prices
but you can't beat our meat
[Laughter]
my father my father worked in a butcher
shop for nine years in brooklyn wow
yeah fred terrace was a butcher
blood brothers here you know so what was
your first job i was a babysitter
i was like 12 13 years old were you a 12
13 years old babysitting 18 year old
girls or like what
was your first job my first job was as a
bus boy at laura's pancake house
wait a minute laura's on bridge on route
nine yes oh that place was awesome
there we go that place is
oh my gosh okay next story here we got
i'm trying to see honorable
okay go to page nine go to page now this
is a good story here page nine
are unemployment benefits uh are
unemployment benefits to new welfare
short-term resistance uh becoming
long-term trap report warrants
expanded federal unemployment benefits
put in place as emergency measuring
during the covet-19 pandemic are on
course to become another long-term
welfare trap
a government fiscal watchdog group warns
in a new report
it has started to look more like welfare
and uh
and more like another piece of the
welfare package it's starting to look
like
a long-term benefits program rather than
a short-term temporary supplement it was
supposed to be
ali fick a senior research fellow with
the foundation for government
accountability said
unemployment insurance programs should
promote work and reject government
dependency
for example an individual can receive 3
700 a month or more than 44 000 dollars
you by staying home
the report continues on top of tax
credits food stamps and state
unemployment benefits an individual can
receive
an additional 1300 a month with the 300
weekly unemployment bonuses are you
kidding me that's 60k a year to stay
home and not do anything
yeah yeah it's it's um you want to be
humanitarian you want to be sensitive
and there are people that
want to go back to work but they have
child care issues and there's still some
covert issues out there
but there's a lot of people who'll come
back to work if you stop the you know a
lot of people want to stay home
because listen let's face it if you're
getting paid to stay home a lot of
people are going to do that
if you're one of those people out there
doing this okay i totally get it
the government is taking all of our
money and putting in their pockets get
yours i get it
but be careful don't stay out too long
man
if you stay out too long and you lose
your edge the the the marketplace is
going to pass you by
well there's a few things that are going
on already to your point you know
amazon's already coming up with robotics
and artificial intelligence because
they're not waiting for people to come
back in addition to that you've got a
lot of individuals that
if you've ever watched somebody that
stayed out and then come back in it's
tough to catch up because technology
changes and evolves so quickly so to
your point about losing your edge
the edge that even if you have an edge
individually you get a lot of catch-up
work to do because technology is
constantly changing so
even six months is a long time to stay
out all three of you hire and i don't
when you look at somebody they've been
out for a year and a half do you
you say no do you say this what's the
reason why
this is not the person for us what do
you see when there's a
an 18-month lapse in in the resume so
there's four there's four qualities i
look for when i hire people it seems to
work it's attitude aptitude initiative
and a sense of urgency so if you have
all four of those i could teach you the
rest but um attitude is really really
important
initiative so somebody's you know
staying home that definitely doesn't
count in the initiative
a sense of urgency you know that's
that's another one that doesn't doesn't
really help
so i think if you have those four
qualities then you'd probably be a
really good hire does that sense of
urgency ring a bell oh my gosh
john carter eight uh keys to leading
change absolutely that's
number one that's number one absolutely
sense of urgency is very hard to win
that's my question
just real quick so if somebody was out
they took the full 18 months they took
the full two years
yeah is that a red flag for you on the
resume like straight up is it
absolutely yes it is absolutely yeah by
the way you know a lot of people will
say things like this listen
um i'll give you an example
uh we we have situ i run a company with
a lot of different agents nationwide and
you know you'll have a lot of people
that will use
excuses and listen all of us may use
excuses at certain times of our lives
but
some more than others there isn't
anybody that's 100 hey i never made an
excuse about anything people
sometimes have a tendency to take an
easy way out some of the guys that we
follow and our leaders are people that
typically make the least excuses and you
admire them you see this guy is freaking
going places
i just want to be able to work with this
guy if you buy into the vision
when we do interviews and somebody says
um
you know there was two years of my
resume that you don't see anything
i took those two years off to take care
of a friend of mine or an aging parent
or this
so you sit there and you you what you
have to do in that moment you have to
say what
either they're telling the truth or
they're not telling the truth
right now in your mind there could be an
odds thing you could say
80 probably this is bs i don't buy it
80 is you work for a company for two
years they fired you was so bad you
don't want to put the boss's name on
there because you don't want us to make
a reference call
and if we make the reference call
they're going to say i'd never hired
this person
you don't want to hire this person so
that happens because sometimes
we'll go online and we're still able to
find where they work and we'll make the
reference call and by calling somebody
who is a former employer and will ask do
you know what job they went to next
sometimes they'll say
yeah you know he went and left us to go
work with xyz company because they gave
him a bigger raise
oh okay great then you call that off
which office was that xyz branch
great you call them hey just want to
follow up a good hr person knows how to
do this stuff they'll call the place and
they'll say
hey john this is uh mary giving you a
call we're checking on
you know bob who i think used to work
with you guys and we're doing a
reference call which bob
bob you know such and such bob yes
are you sure you want to hire this
person well yeah they came for an
interview we like them and we're
thinking about they're in the top three
list you want me to be honest with you
what do you want to tell you
well of course we want you to be honest
with you i would never hire this person
let me tell you what this person did and
then they go boom boom boom boom now
that's if you get lucky because a lot of
times they couch it they want to be very
so you have to read between the lines
because they're not always that
open and honest he's right but he's
right but if you just
you can ask questions to say look
if you had to hire them again would you
zero to ten if they say zero that's all
you need to know
if they say we would consider it okay
good that's something i can judge for it
but we would that we would never hire
this person usually on those usually on
those
unless it's somebody who goes out of
their way glowing stay away
yeah so now because when you want you
don't want to hire somebody mediocre
anyway
now let me flip it let me flip in the
last 18 months in the last 18 months are
there some people that lost their jobs
yes so if i get somebody that tells me
listen i've got to take the last 18
months has
been very hard okay what have you done
i've had three jobs
but it's been the businesses went out of
business and i worked four months or
three months here six months here
i'm okay with that i'm like listen
you're trying you're making an effort
all good
we want somebody like that on the team
let's make an offer to you so
you we when you do the interview behind
closed doors those conversations are
being hacked
by the way same thing with you what you
just think about what you said earlier
yeah
you said earlier 20 down payment to buy
a house right
and then you said they said your income
isn't to what
well that you had a year your lapse of
income that's exactly the same way we
think about it as well
yeah so your year of laps of income when
underwriter worries about giving you
the loan to buy the house it's the same
thing an employer wonders why you had a
year
lapse of no job yeah because that's
that's that's what this is
that says a lot about how you face
adversity as well yeah so are you going
to say okay i've got delta bad hand and
what was me or are you going to say i
got delta bet hand but here's what i did
here's what i did here's what i did
to try and overcome that because you
know failure is not an option for people
who are winners
you know if you're a winner if you're
determined then you come up with an
obstacle
that really shows your character that
you can get past to be clear this was a
once in a century nothing like this has
ever happened before
situation right so you know like you
can't really
i mean you can but you you can't really
justify
holding an eighteen month left by the
way in
industries yeah in industries so for
example
say i run a big restaurant uh you know
chain hypothetical i'm cheesecake
factory
and i'm hiring a gm and i'm in
california
and you were a gm at applebee's you were
a gm at
pick a restaurant wherever you were at
and you've been at gm for 17 years on
your resume from 2012 to 2019
you've been a waiter you know work your
way up to all of being a gm in 2019
2020 happens kobe takes place and you're
in california you're like
dude what the hell you want me to do my
industry
has been shut down restaurants and i'm
in california
i have you have credibility with me
because that's situational
of course every restaurant's been shut
down but now
if it's a different industry that you
could have figured out a way to still
work
and you're telling me you couldn't have
a job i'm sorry i don't give you the
creed instead so
i agree and by the way my comments of
you know you want to try and make it
work
um the covet issue assad i'm saying in
general you know under under
normal conditions when you see those
lapses
you know you want to understand is this
person making excuses or are they trying
to find answers
very interesting because i and pat you
already know this so i'm not i'm not
dropping any bombs here but
i i left i've i've left one job off my
resume my whole life specifically
because i never wanted anybody to call
the boss
and and the reason why is this dude i
was in pharma sales
and um this dude just was like here it
is incredibly aggressive like
glenn gary glenn ross and he would he
would curse people off like right in
front of everybody get in the room and
just curse everybody off
and i i had exceeded my numbers in the
first quarter
and then they raised my numbers and then
i i didn't hit my numbers in the second
quarter but i hit what i had done before
and he laid into me in front of
everybody he was like this close to my
face
screaming at me in a room full of 20
people and i literally just turned to
him and i went
if you don't get out of my face in the
next five seconds every breath you
breathe will be a gift i grant you
[Laughter]
oh i got fired yeah so
uh i've told pat this you know i've the
dude like tried to sit me down he was
like bro that's just unacceptable you
can't say stuff like that was like bro
you're screaming in my face
right here like i don't know about it i
don't care you know about a job i'm a
man first
i gotta i gotta tell you something i
gotta tell you something so and maybe
this will make sense to you you know my
uh three kids okay i have four kids but
one of them you know she's five weeks
and she just you know she's got a
full-time job of
eating sleeping and nursing that's all
she's doing right
and she makes sure that only gets two
hours of sleep like last night it's her
job it's
she's fully committed to it yeah vampire
dad so
you know tico has a story and some
happens
you know with one of my kids he goes you
know fight breaks out him and another
kid go out and he comes home with a
bunch of scratches on his back
and i said what's this all about he's
got all these scratches well you know he
never wants to tell me about anything
that happens to me he's got too much
pride to complain he's not going to say
it
so but when melva's you know going out
there and seeing his back say daddy some
happened to his back
what happened i don't talk about that's
kind of how he is he's like legit
omerta like fully committed to this
whole idea so i'm not gonna stop
yeah so i'm like buddy what happened he
says well you know this
i said what happened is this so i said
you know i sit there as a dad i'm like
you know the the parents whose kids
never do anything wrong my son would
never do such a thing
he would never do such a thing last year
he was taking this
soccer class year and a half i don't
know if you remember this when he goes
to a soccer class
and he's there he knocks a kid out okay
tiko he flat-out knocks the kid out
and when they kick him out jennifer
calls me saying patrick got kicked out
of practice
i'm like tycho why'd you get kicked out
of practice says daddy i got kicked out
of practice because the guy punched me
in the stomach i said tico do not lie to
me
so i'm telling you i'm not lying to you
he punched me in the stomach you've
taught me to not let bullies bully me
i punched him in the face and then he
went to his mommy and daddy cried mommy
and daddy went to the manager and they
kicked me out of the i'm telling you he
punched me first i said okay
i'm gonna call the owner i call the
owner i tell the owner you know the
story i tell you do you know the story
or no
i called the owner i said hey listen my
kid just got kicked out
yes he says you guys kicked him out why
because he punched a kid in the face and
guy was on the floor
and he knocked him out he can't do that
this is a six-year-old he ate
seven-year-olds when he did this
i said he's telling me the other kid
punched him in the stomach first you
guys are running kids over there so i'm
assuming you have cameras just as we do
i said i want you to go look at the
camera and tell me what happened and i
want you to tell me the story because if
you ever want me to write any positive
review about you
i want to know you guys at the right
thing if we were at fault i'm going to
have my son come and apologize to the
kid
but if the other kids have fault i want
to make sure he's held accountable they
said let us get back to two hours later
they call me like this
uh uh here he goes we looked at the
videos and and your son is right
he was punching the stomach first and
then he reacted but the parents never
saw it i'm like
no [ __ ] but how did they respond to that
though let me tell you what i did i'm so
proud of that company by the way
i will tell them recommend them to
everybody
so i picked tico up i said let's go we
took him there i said
he said sir we have to apologize to you
we're so sorry we made this mistake i
said this does nothing to my character
i don't care you apologize to me like
what apology what does an apology do to
me
i said you need to apologize to my son
because that mess with his character
so i take him over there guy comes up i
says here's my son patrick that's the
coach he says i just want to tell you
patrick you were right you were punching
the stomach first and we kicked you out
we apologize
and patrick's like he says do you accept
my apology no
you know like tico except the apology
no accept the apology okay accept the
apology
so he goes to practice anyways this last
week
a similar thing happens he comes from
he's got this whole scratch on his back
this time around i said why'd you get
this well we're playing this game
with kids in school so what's this game
called you're not going to like the game
i said try me
you sometimes you're not going to like
the game i said just tell me the game he
says the game is called
run up to people and call them a name
and run i said there
is no game like that so they ran up this
other kid gave him an idea to run up to
this other kid who was
extremely chubby and they went up them
they called him you know
something something mr fat or something
like that sure and the kid reacts
and again to fight and he beats him up
so i said okay
i said you understand you bullied the
kid he says no i didn't he bullied me i
said no no you started it
tomorrow you got to go to school you got
to apologize to this kid because that's
not cool
i said if you apologize he doesn't
accept that it's on him but if you
apologize and he bulls you after you're
apologizing you've got to punch him in
the face okay
because you cannot let him bully you
because you did your right thing as a
character if he still wants to bully you
now he's taking advantage the
opportunity to stand up for yourself so
he goes to school apologizes to the kid
i said what happened so we're best
friends now we played all day together
that's a fantastic that's great
what's the moral of the story here's
what i've learned dylan doesn't get
bullied
senator doesn't get bullied patrick
sometimes has these things
because it's probably self-inflicted
when i see people
that get fired too often or they always
have an
issue with a boss and it's always
complaining about the company buddy it's
not the company
and i'm not talking about you i'm
talking about people who come to me for
job interviews
you have an issue you see with the brand
and you look for
problems you create problems there's a
reason why you keep losing jobs i called
the guy yesterday
two days ago we're having a conversation
together ask can i ask you a question he
says yeah
i said when you first apply to want to
work at a job this is one of my
insurance says you said you quit your
business
because you wanted to spend more time
with your family he said yes i said so
tell me what kind of money were you
making as a business owner he tells me
the number
i said uh if you were making more money
would you ever shut down the business he
says no i said because i wasn't spending
enough time my family i wish i was
spending more time with my family that's
okay i mean every business owner says
that
but most people that were business
owners that become employees is because
you were probably not a good business
owner he didn't know how to manage
a business then you become an employee
and then when you become an employee
if you don't get results eventually you
could get fired as well as an employee
if you're not getting results
so then says well you know it's not that
it's the fact that i have this i have
that i have this
so then issue comes about the kids same
thing happens as a with the kid as well
so you know what the reality becomes
here's what the reality becomes you said
something uh
uh four weeks ago when we were talking
about somebody you said
people will find a reason to sabotage
themselves to what
yeah to quit something that's hard so
let me wrap up with this and i'll turn
it over to you guys because i've been
listening to you guys for 45 minutes
here's here's here's what will happen
when they sabotage themselves
i have seen more people use family
their kids their faith their past
their parents their upbringing their
ethnicity their nationality the way they
look as an excuse
to not win i can't tell you how many
times i've seen people use all of those
things as excuses
why they can't win versus reasons why
i'm going to go out there make it happen
we all got areas to improve in
if there's anything covert taught us
that exploited expose a lot of our
weaknesses
every one of us let me tell you all my
businesses the weaknesses were shown
all of them when it when insurance when
this thing when [ __ ] hit the fan march
we never saw the policy on zoom ever we
had no clue how to sell a policy on zoom
i'm at the office so four o'clock in the
morning saying how the hell am i going
to teach people how to sell policy on a
zoom i've never sold a policy on the
zoom
we sit in kneecap to kneecap we don't
sit zoom in talking to you
we got exposed we have to sit there and
we got to justice really quickly
we're driven on a convention-based event
we run offices people go to offices
lisa's
all this stuff that we everybody got
exposed in the last 18 months
either you improved and you did
something about it and you made a ton of
money or you didn't
the reality is the last nine months made
more money than my entire career
because we made the right adjustments
people who made the right adjustments
made a lot of money in the last 18
months but if you didn't
here's what the marketplace just found
out about you
uh everything that you were able to hide
the last 18 months that were bad
qualities to not hired officially got
exposed
that's what the market the last 18
months the last 18 months
showed why the market doesn't pay you
what you think you're worth that's the
thing about the market the market
sucks the market is like a six-year-old
kid that will say
hey mr patrick can i ask you a question
yes why is your nose so big and crooked
what do you tell a six-year-old kid he
ain't lying you're gonna say no it's not
yes it is why is your nose so big and
cricket you know cause i've broken it
four times and i got a big nose what am
i gonna do about it
yeah but it looks very weird i've never
seen a nose like that before right okay
that's what a kid will do
last 18 months the market said you're
lazy you're this
you don't want to improve you got a big
ego you think you know it all you make
excuses in the last 18 months we got
brutal honesty from the market nonstop
don't get me wrong it's been a tough
last 18 months it's been challenging
it's been annoying it's been difficult
for a lot of us believe me i'm on more
late night calls the last 18 months than
i've ever been in my career been in
business for 20 years
a lot of late night calls but the
reality of it is we got to expose the
last 18 months it either favored you or
it didn't
so that's what i would say when you talk
about that whole story with some people
that's 18 months when we're hiring
people
i know people in the last 18 months that
made very big names for themselves
that did a lot of good for themselves
anyway so that's that's what it is when
it comes down to
unemployment if you're out there and
you're still collecting unemployment
checks
i got a bigger question for you you know
what the bigger question is the
following
what the hell are your dreams what are
your dreams
have you compromised all of your dreams
have you compromised all your dreams for
a flip and paycheck
you mean a four thousand dollar a month
stimulus check is worth you
compromising your dreams for the rest of
your life i don't understand that part
you need to tell me when you watch a
movie like pursuit of happiness
and you see a story of chris gardner
whom i brought up in 2008 in front of
five thousand people with mary lou rhett
and i introduced at an event
you see a story like chris gardner how
he wins in pursuit of happiness and at
the end he wins
and he's a multi-million and he wins for
his son you tell me that doesn't get you
emotional
of course you mean to tell me when you
watch rocky and he wins and you see the
robots and rocky iv and all this other
stuff and his dreams are becoming a
reality you mean to tell me that doesn't
fire you up to want to do 200 push-ups
afterwards
you mean to tell me when you watch some
of these movies and people's dreams are
becoming a reality you're not sitting
there saying
i have some dreams biggest thing with
the stimulus is the fastest way
to steal you from dreaming and it's the
easiest way to get you to control
because the more you dream
and you innovate and you challenge
status quo the more they lose
the more they give you money and you
stop thinking about dreaming reading
books improving yourself the easier you
are to control
so if there's anything when it comes
down to money being given away to us
you just have to keep thinking about i
get it three months i get it two months
i get it a month i get it four months
maybe six months
if it's 18 months you're kind of you
know exploiting the opportunity getting
more money and quite frankly
you decrease your market value in the
last 18 months while
inflation went up while everything is
more expensive so you're kind of going
to be very broke the next five years
and life's going to be very hard you
thought it was hard two years ago shit's
about to hit the fan the next five years
this is why you want to use
opportunities like this to recreate
yourself and many did barry
oh i totally agree with you i mean this
is when you have an adversity you either
decide to make an opportunity out of it
or it's what was me so
uh amen to that man you guys are very
quiet adam gerard
yes like
all right let's talk about bill maher
bill maher says tokyo olympics are out
uh woking the oscars proving cancer
cultures and insanity that is swallowing
up the world have you guys seen that
video what do you say
right when you get a chance to see this
wonderful absolutely sick wonderful
absolutely sick
by the way bill maher today
has replaced what jon stewart was doing
10 years ago
okay do you guys remember when john
stood brought nancy pelosi and called
her out on everything and she's like you
can't say that
you just cannot say what you just said
right there so it didn't matter if it
was left right middle we need people
like bill maher
so bill maher again another one of these
videos that went viral
please don't make the olympics into the
oscars bill maher says
last april as he reminded the audience
he said the theme of the year's oscars
show was
we dare you to be entertained as
producers he griped
seemed determined not to let the
audience forget uh forget
for a moment the injustices and
deficiencies the human
condition the tokyo summer games in mars
view have outdone hollywood he reeled
off a series of instances where
officials and creative staffers
faced consequences over decade-old
behavior and in one case
the opening ceremony musical director
was ousted over a 1994 interview in
which he admitted
to bullying fellow students when he was
a child in school
he also ridicu media coverage of surfing
uh becoming a olympic sport in tokyo the
social press wrote
that having surfing in the games exa
cultural appropriation with racial
indignities
that's because uh non-hawaiians have
popularized
and mainstreamed the sport with deep
spiritual and communal
meaning for its original participant the
article's headline described the
competition
as whitewash event as to changes as to
charges that he stands uh
means he has moved farther to the
political right a place on the spectrum
giving to reflexively denouncing cancer
culture mars said
my politics have not changed but i am
reacting to politics
that have powerful story by the deadline
it was a great video to watch patrick it
was i thought so as well i mean he was
so spot on on so many things
and to talk about you know going back
when someone was six years old and
something they did as a kid and that's a
reason to terminate them today
that's just absolutely absurd but they
get away with it when is this cancelled
culture going to stop what is this whole
thing and
when are people gonna stand up and say
enough of this [ __ ]
and just stop why do you think it's
creating so much momentum though
why momentum though that's the part you
know you know what cancer culture to me
is here's what cancer culture to me is
the only person that can do cancer
culture
is a person who can walk on water that
is the only person that has a moral
authority it's a witch hunt man
i don't know if you got what i just said
when i'm saying yeah yeah yeah we got
you so if you walk on water
you listen you have all the right i'm
sorry i may hear you you know you're
right
i can't walk on water buddy if you can
walk on water try to cancel us
well what i want more than anything else
is uh for them to admit that they're
watching our podcast because that entire
dialogue is what we talked about on
thursday
you asked us why are we not watching the
olympics i said it's just not fun
anymore
the woke olympics aren't fun at all and
then we turned around
and we talked about the the look you
know
everybody thinks we're right wing we're
this or that we're dead in the middle
man
the culture's gone so far left so fast
so when bill maher is saying that
i haven't gone right he's coming to the
same realization
that the rest of us have came and be
like man am i am i have i gone right if
i'm
am i thinking about no i'm here i've
been here
the culture's sprinting left so if
they're to the left of frickin trotsky
now
everybody's gonna seem to the right of
them even michael rappaport one of the
most annoying people on earth
this dude goes from on tuesday talking
about get your vaccine or you're a jerk
and then he's crying on tick-tock two
days later like so let me get this
straight i can still
i can still get rid of i can still give
people the virus if i get rid of the
vaccine
i'm a super spread or not like come on
man these guys they're having
existential crisis
here because they're trying to fit in
with this with this
cult they want to fit in with these
elites but the illegal well because
because that because they're worried
about the ramifications if they don't
and that's the thing is that they'll be
canceled out if they don't so
everybody's everybody's treading so
lightly this is supposed to be
the idealism of inclusivity right all we
want to include we don't want you
except if you disagree with them because
as soon as you disagree with them that
you know so
so long as you agree with them then they
want to include you that's a good point
guys send a
guy send a tweet uh and he said to me
you know cancel culture by the way you
guys know the porn star we talked about
she messaged me
very upset she was happy with you though
she liked you a lot but she was upset
with the rest of us
and say what's up say what's up no she
said good things about you i gotta i got
a friend adam that'll buy you some white
clothes no no
not a fan of anybody else but he was a
fan of this so this one guy responds to
me and says have you noticed your view
numbers
on this are being censored meaning my
whole idea about trump and obama this
guy's saying have you noticed the views
on this have been censored
you're not getting views listen the only
thing that i see is the suggestion side
which you see the if the audience wants
to get this message out there they can
get the message out here's what i said
to the guy
i said i don't believe the right message
can be censored long term
common sense can't be censored truth
can't be
censored temporarily yes permanently
no way in the world mario said that no
way in the world but mario said that and
he said that to us in a group checks and
it was it was a good point that he says
the truth always comes out
my fear my anxiety and my trepidation i
agree the truth always does come out
but it doesn't always come out in your
generation it doesn't always come out in
your lifetime
i don't want to live knowing that i was
lied to
and die knowing that the wrong people
maintained control you know it's a flag
carrier you know what a fly carrier is
what's a flag carrier to you the
definition of a flag carrier don't know
what's a flag carrier when you think
about somebody that takes your message
and runs with it and took the wild and
so delivers it so flag carriers this is
going to sound a little weird and it's
not going to turn anybody on so brace
for impact this is not going to be that
exciting but it's going to
hopefully make some sense to what you're
saying here right and what you're asking
about here right now
some of us in life are flag carriers
some of us in life are the byproduct of
a flag carrier
i am a byproduct of my dad and my mom
sacrificing everything they had
including their marriage
everything they knew the language they
spoke the places they ate
they became the flag carriers to bring
their kids to u.s and my dreams became a
reality one of the best lines that grow
that lady said on fox and friend
she said here's a man who's born in a
born in iran but he's made an america
yeah kai's like that's got to be a book
one day born in iran made in america
right
okay my dad but my dad no one's going to
know my dad except for me telling the
world about my dad
my dad was a cashier at a 99 cent store
he's a flag carrier because of him
i work my ass off to make sure he for
the rest of his life can say
that's my son and the reason why he's
got the life is because i carry the flag
to allow him to have the life that he
has the man too sometimes
he loves you about he loves both of you
guys sometimes we forget that
we don't know what role we're playing in
life okay
sometimes you're not the one that's
going to be the next president sometimes
you're not the one that's going to be
the next billionaire the next innovator
the next governor the next senator
sometimes you may play the role of a
flag carrier sometimes you may be
playing the role of a flag here in an
era that other people don't have the
courage to stand up and say here's what
we're going to be doing
but you're helping the next generation
win nobody wants that job who the hell
wants that job
who wants to be to be the veteran that
goes to war and defense for freedom for
other people in the back
that are going to spit him in the face
when he lands in the airport comes back
and saying who the hell are to go to
work like
did you do you realize how many my
friends i just lost who the hell wants
to be that person
that's not going to be appreciated by
most people and then you lost two of
your friends and your life's on the line
what is a big deal about that that's a
flag carrier we have to go back to
recognizing these flag carriers that
have given us the opportunity to live
the life that we live today
george washington flag carrier lincoln
flag carrier mlk
flag carrier john fk jfk flag carrier
these are flag carriers they carry the
flag for us to have a better life
i think uh you know the idea of not
wanting to be a flag carrier is the fact
that some of us are not going to lose
you know are going to lose some of our
opportunities having our dreams become a
reality i want my kids to have the
opportunity to live the life they want
to live
you know and and their daddy's going to
do their part to have that become a
reality here's a final thing i want to
do before we wrap up
great podcasts lots of great commentary
people hopefully you enjoy what we
talked about today if you enjoyed it
smash the subscribe button
uh if you want to see barry back on
again with real estate topics that he
gave this is the second time he's back
on barry thank you for your insight
always very helpful
gang i want to tell you guys as well in
about four weeks we're doing a live
event called the vault everybody's been
looking forward to this
everything's been shut down if if i'm
for anything i'm for us
coming together i think when people try
to cancel barack obama's birthday with
700 people i'm
all for we got to come together i'm all
for events taking place i'm hosting an
event
uh next week we're going to vegas
there's going to be 12 000 people in
vegas that's at the mgm grand arena
but four weeks from now we're hosting an
event at the diplomat
in miami call the vault it'll be a
three-day event
entrepreneurs c-suite executives sales
people from around the world are going
to come together
to share strategies if there's anything
i can tell you from what happened the
last two years
the last 18 months you need to be
around other people in similar
situations like you who are finding
ways to win at the highest level you got
to find the right community
to be a part of if you haven't yet
registered for the vol conference
gary kasparov who they call him the goat
of chess
he was first place for 251 months no
one's ever been able to do that as a
grandmaster
he'll be there because of the whole
ideas you got to know your next 10 15
moves
we have a billy bean who took the a's
with a team that had nothing to
what they the 21 game win streak is that
one that 21 game
money ball movie he'll be their money
ball and then we have phil heath's going
to be there
tom ellsworth's going to train on how to
raise money i'm about to make two more
announcements adam's going to be our
entire camp's going to be that the vault
if you haven't yet registered kai what
is the link can we put that below it's
got
thevaultconference.com if you haven't
registered the ticket prices
today you can get ticket prices for this
event what's the number right now 697
general tickets
co tickets already been sold out i think
founder's already been sold out we only
got three categories right now to buy
tickets if you haven't bought a ticket
yet
go to thevaultconference.com get a
ticket bring a friend bring your spot
bring your family
and we're looking forward to spending
three days with you at the vault
conference
in miami first week of september
with many other entrepreneurs c-suite
executives around the world having said
that this has been a great podcast i've
enjoyed it
very adam gerard we will do this again
thursday and by the way
oh friday we got zooby zooby's going to
be here
that's right zooby's going to be here
this friday larry elder reached out if
you guys want to see larry elder come on
the podcast go on twitter
tag him tag me hashtag pdppodcast maybe
we'll get him on the podcast take
everybody bye bye everybody bye-bye
you